two
good Monday top of the Monday to you
Laden lassies
kings and queens
is the History Podcast we're here
[Music]
oh yeah
September 26th
we're having some technical issues so if
you when you have the feed let me know
if it looks normal
that looks good to me I'm watching it
okay yeah beautiful
uh today's episode is sponsored by Babel
and hellofresh we love so well
man I need a haircut so bad dude come on
who's gonna share this wool
you know what do people I think it's
about time we start making clothing out
of human hair think about it
I'm growing my hair back people think
about it there's so many of us
you know why we got to put the the Sheep
through all that [ __ ]
let's just cut our own hair there it is
beautiful who wouldn't want to wear that
wow
cut them off that's luxurious
um
hello to tick tock and uh Instagram I
want to say to my tater tots out there
I'm a Daddy you the [ __ ] up Andrew's
Gone no he's not on the internet anymore
this is all you've got okay I'm the top
G now I'm the top e
for Ethan
what's the name of that uh hash brown at
McDonald's
I was trying to think because they're
Tater Tot so I was kind of give them a
little pet name some kind of potato uh
some kind of breakfast potato but okay
my little My Little Country fries yeah
what is up my little country fries this
is your daddy Ethan I'm gonna teach you
how to get laid and how to become a
billionaire where's my daddy
also super excited to say that this
shirt right here is an XL and my fat ass
has been wearing 2XL
you know for for feels like forever now
uh Lena brought this shirt out and I
said you know what
I think I'm gonna need to XL because
these two excels are looking pretty big
on me I mean take a look what do you
guys think
it's a little it's a little snug
that's great I mean it's a little snug
more snug than I'm used to but it's a
good shirt it's pretty cool pretty
pretty good fit
ah yeah by the way speaking of Teddy
fresh this is uh from the new collection
this shirt is
magnificent it is so beautiful it is so
nice
um
if you go to teddyfresh.com there's two
colorways here it's called the blocked
rugby think you will
this colorway is really beautiful too
and but you know this one's just classy
I like it also if you look at take a
look over at Dan who's never looked more
hyped out oh that's hot no yeah you
should lift the chair or something man
the people got to see yeah there you go
I mean Dan is swag the [ __ ] out bro
look at that and that of course is Teddy
Fresh's um
uh a trademark uh uh a paintbrush
tie-dye
yes anyone else wearing Teddy fresh
uh yeah but not from today's drug
or thank you guys I'm gonna wear the
other one on Wednesday ooh exciting so
so yeah um so guys teddyfresh.com thank
you also um got a very generous donation
from Cameron Subway Street fam it's my
fiancee I seven year anniversary today
she's the one that told me to watch H3
if you could please uh give her a pop-up
bless and some of my love Abigail okay
Papa plus Abigail we love you how about
Abigail me and Neil are about to have
our 10th anniversary also just real
quick at the top of the show here I have
a very exciting announcement for our
members
I've been trying to think what can I do
for our beautiful members who support us
who love us so well you know let's be
honest what what do we do for members so
far pretty much nothing right pretty
much nothing
keep the drum roll going well what do we
do for them Dan well there's the BTS
that Abe spends a lot of time yes is
exclusive that's hot yeah and we have a
whole community on the Discord that's
very fun uh Early Access the bone access
to the Bone Zone which is I'm personally
a big fan of like the bone Zone yeah
there's a there's a bone Zone channel on
the Discord what is that it's mostly
just people posting Gifts of Bones and
skeletons okay not no sexual assault oh
no no no not that kind of bone Zone
look yes so um okay the bone zone so
there you hope but I really wanted to
bring step it up and reward you guys
uh big time
and also so listen up members and
prospective members
it's been my dream to do five episodes a
week if many of you know
Monday through Friday keep it going Zach
thank you
and so my dream is becoming reality
I am doing on Tuesday for members only
an extra show a week this is huge news
guys
yes so so you know the members you guys
are just so incredible
thank you guys so much so
the idea is basically
it's a solo podcast there's no video
and it's just me talking about uh
you know what's going on it's personal
it's cool it's exciting it's hip
slick stuff it's slick stuff cool stuff
the conversation begins and um yay I'm
glad you guys are so excited in the chat
I'm so happy to see that yeah uh like
for example I just I already filmed it
last night Sunday night and we're gonna
post it on Tuesday
it was all about Rosh Hashanah
right or Yom Kippur which one is it
that's for sure you're asking me yeah I
don't know you just did a whole hour on
it
yes and I I this [ __ ] is the lore on
this stuff I was kind of talking about
it there's a thing called the 613
Mitzvahs did you guys know about this
the Jews I was vaguely aware of it I
wouldn't have been able to name 600 yeah
so so I got one on this crazy Sidetrack
because during the New Year's dinner you
have a bunch of pomegranate seeds and
those represent the 613 Mitzvah so I was
like what the [ __ ] that's a lot of
Mitzvahs so I start looking into these
and these are in shame bro some of the
Mitzvahs is like don't [ __ ] a goat
well that's good that's good advice
nobody's Blown Away one of them was like
you know you gotta codify that there's a
whole part about incest so like don't
[ __ ] your dad don't [ __ ] and these are
all different rules don't [ __ ] me down
don't [ __ ] your dad's sister don't [ __ ]
your sister don't [ __ ] yourself it's
like whoa doing this down hold on that's
really interesting
[Music]
I think we just got uh age restricted
if we didn't get age restricted on
Friday's episode
it ain't happening
don't even say that Dylan keep that
between us okay
yeah but actually you know what's fun
too I was I was like man I could say
whatever I want on this because it
doesn't matter so I was dropping C bombs
see you next Tuesdays I called the queen
I see you next Tuesday hmm
hey
um also I joked about bombing stuff not
actual threats okay I just scrubbed
through it because I did a pass to kind
of clean it up and and add some audio
enhancement should I should I maybe
scream no no no it's fine it's fine okay
but I was like who's a slightly delayed
I was like who's gonna watch this
I could make a straight up death threat
and probably be oh boy what's your
profanity but I didn't obviously and I
never would that's the point I never
would right just never
do it it is death yeah so so it's an
hour long
I thought you know I thought it was fun
actually I thought it turned out pretty
fun I'm gonna keep doing them every
Tuesday I'm gonna try my best to do it
every Tuesday I don't want to paint
myself into like a corner but I'll tell
you me and either are going on vacation
coming up here to Hawaii for a 10th
anniversary and I'm gonna bring
a zoom h4n that's right that which is an
advanced mic so we can get some good
very Advanced good audio I I gotta say I
like that
you did did a podcast talking about
Jewish culture and stuff like that oh
thank you Zach I find that very
interesting and I'd like to hear more
like I'm not even Joe oh let's just keep
the Jewish lore going I think I kind of
like that Rabbi Klein it is funny I I I
was I was learning along with you guys
and I thought the whole thing was pretty
wild
because I was just like yo have you guys
read this like
I don't know if all y'all Jews know what
you signed up for I'm just saying this
some of those rules are pretty wild
well the ones you listed off all sounded
pretty oh yeah no some of them are wild
okay
but you know you could talk about oh
they go don't commit sodomy with your
dad I was like whoa I didn't even need
that one written down I'm cool you you
think that you don't need to write these
down but then you got some dad [ __ ]
out there yeah where where's the rule
where's the rule that I can't do it well
there it is because of the 613 Mitzvahs
you know what's not in there any one
single rule
about
essay sexual crimes not one it's like
you all thought about every Sports wide
is sideways [ __ ] up incest but nobody
ever thought to put a sexual crime in
there it's crazy and it's a sexual
experience bestiality would be a sexual
crime well against another human being I
see they say don't [ __ ] a beast they
call them beasts I said well who's a
beast right my dog's not a beast he's a
he's a sweetheart can I [ __ ] my dog I
don't know
I need a rabbi to interpret this I did
not [ __ ] my dog
yeah also just to clarify it is Audio
Only
um and and it's just a lot of fun so the
new the so that episode will be up
tomorrow
for all members
and I just thank you guys all so much
for your support and just you know you
guys are the best you guys do so much
for us and I welcome all new members too
you're gonna you're actually not gonna I
feel like we have a really good offering
of rewards now between a b between my
thing between the Discord we have
occasional member only live streams yeah
oh and maybe we should take this
opportunity to remind everybody that on
this Wednesday
members will be given first dibs on
tickets to our live show later this year
oh yeah my God I forgot about that yeah
so yes
um obviously there's a shitload of the
four episodes free for everybody you
know but I just want to make as much
love and support for those who do
financially support us and uh no
no pirating this episode
if you download the episode and share it
with people who are not paying me five
dollars a month you're gonna be banned
this is this is a Mitzvah that he's
created this is the 614th Mitzvah you're
declaring right now the Mitzvah is you
shall pay for the member before you
listen to The Exclusive Tuesday podcast
Tanner Klein's Tuesday
speaking of which we should come up with
a name for it we don't have to do it
right now that's true like I when I was
exporting I was like I don't know what
this is called that's true I don't have
a name for it yeah
I am Unleashed bro I'd say what the [ __ ]
I want bro what was that book Tuesdays
With Maury Murray was another book
called Tuesday yeah that's when the guy
would visit the old man every Tuesday
right how was that Tuesdays with more I
mean it's about a dying old man oh well
there you go spot right on the nose Zach
thank you Ethan
actually like Ethan Unleashed
but actually you know I'm really happy
I'm doing this I've always thought about
about this idea of doing um
like a solo just voice uh kind of more
of a
personal uh chat so I'm really curious
what you guys think if you guys enjoy it
I scrubbed through earlier too it feels
very much like the Ethan Klein Channel
but more along that's what it reminded
me of as well yeah so that's nice I
think that's good I think yeah thank you
yeah so um I'll keep thinking of
something but yeah so I'm excited I'm
glad you guys are excited too there you
go happy happy times good times to be a
H3 fan there it is
a Happy New Year to everybody there was
actually a lot of Mitzvahs about like
being cool to
non-jews
enter the boys yeah they're like don't
they're like don't scam boys
don't you know honor your deals with
them and they said one was interesting
they said you have to loan goy's money
with interest koi is just like a
non-jewish person it's a non-goem is a
non-jewish person like a muggle
yes
exactly
well don't you have a name for a non-uh
a Muslim all right not that I know I
mean like they say like people the book
or Infidel a catheter is a non-believer
I don't know Infidel maybe but I'm just
kidding but goem is not necessarily an
insult issue yeah yeah you know so I
don't know if it's there it is
hmm
fun times
Muggles aren't installed a mug blood is
an insult
just
like like Harry Potter lore like a half
blood would that be not pure blooded
yeah okay
mug blood
like that damn Hermione was she mug
blooded she was dirty ass mug-blooded
freak yeah shame on her
well there it is guys we got actually
some fun stuff ooh another should I
announce Thursday what's going on on
leftovers oh yeah I mean me it's
happening so when our son have nailed
down
our Dream guest for leftovers we've been
we've been trying we've been trying and
it's finally happened it is Donald Trump
that's right he's coming off oh no sorry
liver King liver King even better
[Applause]
I'm excited man he's coming in with his
chef
he's gonna be preparing some raw liver
for us I know once I take one bite of
that I'm gonna get some like flesh
eating amoeba or some [ __ ]
you know
I do welcome tapeworms though like kind
of but that's cool I just got done
eating some Seer testicles
yeah
yeah so I think that'll be fun you know
Hassan is very out I like got that Alpha
testosterone thing so I don't know put
them together maybe yeah wait have you
told Hassan or is he gonna find out when
somebody Clips this right now okay I
told him
he's excited sweet
so lots of good stuff happening eh
um
as you guys can see
huge news in the David dobrik world
absolutely shocking developments
this article broke
I think I saw this on like my news feed
or some [ __ ] I don't remember
but I was like okay David dobrik
um
David dobrik Jeff whittick new risks of
esque excavator stunt don't blame me
this this article is awesome
uh yes so in a court filing he responded
to Jeff's lawsuit
basically saying that it's not his fault
because he knew the risks which is
awesome because
it's nice that he got him to admit that
because you know that's kind of what
Jeff always thought
but now he actually gets to see him
write that
you know
under
uh perjury or whatever threat of perjury
what is up with David is he totally off
the scene is he just on Tick Tock uh I'm
seeing him on Snapchat a little bit but
that's pretty much it he's super popular
on Tick Tock still yeah
does he have no income right now
I'm sure he does
he got people you got angles yeah got
angles we never even dreamed of
last upload on his main Channel on
YouTube was five months ago wow and then
what about his podcast Channel
uh what the hell is that you use
let's say views last episode was also
five months ago wow he's really laying
low man yeah
I wonder how much cash he like stuffed
away before all this because he from
what I understand he did hire a very
uh probably expensive Boutique
entertainment lawyer to to fight this
for him
well there's rumors of it being uh
Johnny Depp's lawyer at one point I
don't think that's yeah I don't think
it's confirmed no
grumpy because I actually looked up the
attorneys and did some Ops okay and then
Jeff's lawyer is pretty funny it's like
some random injury attorney from Vegas
but that's it you got to get that
Scrappy dude who's going to do it on pro
bono or not pro bono but get a little
chunky should have called Jacob
he should have called Jacob I don't know
if he works on a contingency or whatever
you call it
because it's a good chance when you take
that kind of work you know you don't
even get paid
by the way thank you Luis 50 bucks
thanks for the laughs and Goofs issue
podcast has been a light and some of the
dark moments of my life
thank you man love you thank you for the
bed
hello
yeah so um
should be really interesting to see what
actually comes from this man
but do you I mean I know David was like
on top of the world and made a lot of
money but he also spends a lot of money
so I wonder like how how much can he
really be sitting on in terms of
a pile of cash
without working at all who wants to lose
some money today
but he is active on Tick Tock right
let's see Tick Tock yeah but more
Snapchat I think
really this is from four days ago that's
right well you haven't seen Jason like
this look at this take it off dude what
the hell bro whoa
yo that's what happens when uh
don't say it don't say it I don't even
know what you were going for but it
can't be anywhere good no let's stop
today
save it save it first save it for
Tuesday yeah yeah I probably shouldn't
say I'm just gonna say when you don't
eat as much buttered noodles
[Music]
no no good that's still too much
yo but props to Jason that's insane
he's pretty old too it's not a filter
wait it flex your dad oh my God that's
super impressive I gotta say
well
actually I would I wanted to say Jason
seems like he's doing well he's got a
new podcast and he's got guests there
and stuff so it's pretty interesting to
see
David has abducted this kid knocking off
John at the airport he's going to
Chicago but what he doesn't know is that
I'm coming with him
and we're not going to Chicago what
we're going to Paris
wait what
dude I told my mom I already called her
who is this who was this child he's
abducting the parents I think that's a
childhood friend that yeah that's a I've
seen him in older videos yeah I'm not
sure he's the one who's I he didn't uh
uh rip out of his head yeah there's a
lot can happen in Paris
I knew you were driving here for no
reason I [ __ ] knew it Tyler's like
why are you driving me to the airport
God he must have made a lot of money
during that time because like to not
have an income for five months sheesh
from that
what was it called dyspo there's no way
that ever turned into anything dyspo I
know I haven't even heard of it since
you left that actually may have been
like hooked him up fat if they had to
pay him out that's a financial decision
of his life too I feel like that's why
excavator around sorry go ahead look it
may have been it may have actually been
it's interesting to think that like if
he got paid out like 20 million for that
dumb [ __ ] and he refused to give Jeff
money
but he got he's like yo that excavator
hooked me the [ __ ] up
by the way thank you for all the gifted
Subs you guys thank you excited for
Tuesday Katie cat meow if I gif
uh Happy Birthday Riley
um what were you what were you saying
yeah about uh the dyspo and then I think
he has like a a perfume company yeah
that he pushed pushes a lot I think he's
make oh I think I think a lot of people
I think his younger fans definitely
bought it I'm on his Instagram right now
he has a few things linked for purchase
like what yeah like
um shop happy face which is that's his
brand the Hat he's wearing there's that
there's that's so funny bro his perfume
holy [ __ ] dude and by the way he
literally is like he literally just
called it David's perfume by David
dobrik he has the drink of the summer
and he also has zela Fitness and protein
holy [ __ ] man this guy's Diversified
I'm only in the clothing game I gotta
make perfume do you think he made a lot
off his uh Discovery show too no no I
bet he didn't make sure he probably got
paid very little for that in my opinion
because when you try to go to
traditional media
they're like well
we'll make it but we can't really pay
you any money until we know if this show
is going to work or not I Missed The
Mark with that one you know because a
show like that they have like a half a
million dollar or more budget per
episode
so I doubt he made a lot on that one
[ __ ] you you just named your
clone David's perfume
no it's clickbait
isn't it no it's called David's perfume
by David David perfume dude
delete uh just a quick update your Tick
Tock has been taken down wow that was
ready that's a record moving fast here
let me see the reason because shut up
what was the reason let's see
after suspended
misinformation you gotta love those guys
man miss info classic that's where they
got me they just report whatever right
okay you keep I mean my account's fairly
big
I'm not the biggest I have two million
followers right and whenever I end the
live it goes congratulations you had
more than 96 of other live viewers
somebody should really [ __ ] look at
this
am I spreading Miss info like what are
you talking about
Instagram says that's why we are better
Instagram chat yeah there we are I mean
Tick Tock is
such a cesspool
is our home and it is also our home at
the same time it's hard it's a tough
decision it's my home
it's his home it's our home here let me
wait it says I can go live already again
she's not going anywhere that [ __ ] it
who cares
yes so um
look how sensual this is do you buy this
that he's attracted to that woman that
he's this is the face of a man who
is wearing perfume it's sensual
it's hot there are high school locker
rooms that smell like David dobrik all
across the country
that he's even got testimonials Dan
don't be a hater I love it it's my go-to
for every day I just ordered my second
bottle I love it there it is who are you
to question that I said I love of it it
smells exactly what I wanted without me
even knowing it I love the magnetic cap
overall a hundred thousand out of ten
that's impossible that's literally
impossible it doesn't make sense it
doesn't make sense like come on he made
a campaign video let's take a look
I love perfume commercials this is like
right at the beginning of the pandemic
oh man he must have made a killing on
this [ __ ]
wait beginning of the pandemic wasn't
already canceled by then or no he wasn't
no no no no no no no no no yeah he
stopped vlogging right when the pandemic
started right the I forget that
Frenemies was like a pandemic podcast
yeah like losing all track of time man
from the since the pandemic
Gabrielle uh says she's coming from New
York for the LA show let's [ __ ] go
hopefully it doesn't get canceled and I
have to refund your ticket like last
time
[Applause]
hopefully not yep
no it's not gonna get close
I know we've told this story before but
the last time we did a live show with
like
we included an agent I hate working with
agents
from one of these big agencies and it
was just such a train wreck
that we canceled it had to refund people
and then we started getting all these
emails being like yo I bought tickets to
go and I got a hotel I spent thousands
of dollars
and I felt so bad I just started sending
everybody money so it ended up actually
costing me like probably like like
twenty thousand dollars
so let's not do that again let's not do
that yeah
all right David's perfume guys get your
uh credit cards out
foreign
music here that says I want perfume
there it is
dude this is so stupid we know you're
not we know you're not
with her bro we know you just like to
watch you know you know what I mean
like if somebody's in the corner just
watching I don't necessarily want to
smell them you want to forget they're
there
like if this is realistic it should be
him in the corner jerking off
and then
and then they go what's that smell and
they go oh David's here
[Music]
that's wrong but that's real though
that's that's the truth
oh God hey another 50 Dono from Lenny
happy to consider all the new member
perks as my birthday present thanks oh
yeah oh thank you awesome thank you guys
very excited about the new podcast thank
you all members
oh my God David
is this how is this how couples are
supposed to act that I don't understand
uh is this
is this oh no it hit somebody in the eye
it took out another eye with that
firework come out
like nobody's buying this David
I bet you I disagree I bet it made a lot
of money for him yeah no I know I know
but this ad is just ugh it's very sexual
ad but he's he doesn't have sex that's
like his whole thing is that like he
only watches that's just our no that's
real bro
what do you mean Liza koshy who he dated
for like two or three years said they
never had sex or at least like one I
don't know if she's implied that they
never had sex oh yeah yeah I can't say
it but I I know what you're talking
about it was on Whitney Cummings podcast
yeah I forgot what she said but she
didn't say anything and then Karina
cough is always talking about how she's
trying to sleep with him and he's like
he's like asexual or something which is
fine you know or he like he just likes
to watch
but don't you guys think I'm going down
the the duper call now but
looking back at that him dating Liza was
such opportunistic snakery I don't think
he ever liked her at all
and obviously I never watched back then
so I I honestly have no idea what their
Dynamic was I mean what was it like on
camera
obviously I don't know anything about
that
I've never been in the bedroom with them
I don't know so so this is all taken
with a
[ __ ] mountain of salt right
but he started dating her when she was
like the biggest [ __ ] thing on
YouTube you remember that Liza koshy she
was everywhere she was the new YouTube
darling I see so she was bigger than him
in the beginning it's way bigger she was
like the biggest thing President Obama
when he was still president yeah I am
yeah huge on Vine
she was huge super talented I like her I
liked her videos but she would post
whatever and it was getting like insane
views shoot and so
all of a sudden they start dating
and on camera well you know David dobrik
nothing on camera is real um
uh
and then she decides she doesn't want to
be on YouTube anymore I guess she tried
to Pivot to more traditional media
and then all of a sudden they're
breaking up and then I'm understanding
that they never even had [ __ ] sex
I saw somebody in the comments or in the
chat State she said that they had sex
twice in there oh
breasts they had sex twice that's what
I'm saying dude
like
wait wait hold on hold on I'm just going
off on what the chat said oh no I'm
pretty sure let's just set that it's
okay Trisha said that Eliza didn't
gotcha Eliza was on Whitney Cummings
wait Liza told Trisha they only had no
no no no no Trisha told you that oh
Eliza was on Whitney Cummings podcast
not not more than a few months ago I
think and she said that she had never
come before okay Mission failed bro I
mean that's a very different thing no
but notice they've never had well it's
true
stop saying it's true it's this is all
rumored hold on hold on she said
somewhere they only had sex twice where
does that come from
I don't know if she said that hey wait
that comes from Olivia's disagreeing
she's saying that that was just Trisha
wait I'm confused Trisha just said that
without
I don't know nothing to back it up
Trisha you know years and years okay but
so that was like a Trisha exclusive
as far as we know I'm pretty sure that
Liza hasn't said that but okay I got it
I got you I got you cut them off
I already gave the biggest [ __ ]
disclaimer in the world literally put my
body in a rock of salt and preserve me
there forever that's how much you should
not take this seriously I believe it you
know what I mean your beef jerky my life
into salt this is my last Prince of salt
anyway
um but don't you does anyone get that
vibe that David was like totally using
her nobody I I don't know I felt again I
was I've never ever been plugged into
the Vlog Squad so I do not even have an
opinion on this I used to watch and I
kind of got the feeling that was kind of
mutual they just stayed together for the
content they both they both yeah yeah
that could be probably
sex
it's a little [ __ ] up though I felt I
felt bad for Liza because
I don't know she let they had like this
big breakup video and then she left
YouTube which is such a shame because
she was like Queen
and I mean I guess she's loving her
traditional media career
but it seems like she's not she's been
kind of reduced to just like
some red carpet interviewer which is
cool
but I feel like she's more than that
does she uh have a talk show or did that
get canceled she has a talk show I
didn't know that she did a super I don't
know if she's still doing those videos
but she did a video with Will Smith when
he started his YouTube career and that
was a really huge deal
that must have been a long time ago it
was yeah yeah you know I just thought I
thought she was so talented and stuff
and but but you know I wish her the best
I blame David though at least she has
both eyes still well she had that
YouTube
she had a YouTube Red show or YouTube
premium the Liza koshy show lies on
demand okay that's what I was thinking
three seasons uh well the last season
came out a year ago so yeah there's
three seasons of that so that probably
took up a lot of her time wait people
are saying she has a show yeah it's
called lies on demand no but like right
now
or I mean the last season came out 11
months ago you think they're filming a
new season she doesn't even make YouTube
videos
oh
well there it is folks there it is uh
David dobrik here uh
in a wild romantic Affair
and speaking of uh move on uh we are at
34 minutes there it is we should do our
advertisements well hold on now I'm
trying to get to the bottom of this
whole perfume Fiasco
what
would the bottom be in this scenario at
what point do we
well they really nailed the
pointlessness of perfume commercials
it does have the right vibe
yeah yeah it does selling a lifestyle
how many views does this have 7.5
million [ __ ] me he sold a lot of that
[ __ ] what I'm saying 7.5 million people
watch that dumbass ad
let's make a perfume that's what I think
yeah a gold balls
like what should we do because it's so
easy like perfumes are so cheap and easy
to make literally just put like some
vanilla and some tincture
can I yeah can I be in one of the ads
for this absolutely man because I really
I really love that Johnny Depp
commercial for the Dior one I would love
to recreate that scene for scene with
you bro I would that would be an honor
dude bury your guitar or whatever the
[ __ ] yeah
now that'd be funny we should do that
either way yeah I mean that's a good
idea good ass video
um
damn
what kind of perfume could we sell
because people look at me you know I
stink
like just look at me who am I or well
maybe someone stinky is better equipped
to make perfume yeah you don't stink I
know but I look stinky young gravy said
you smell amazing
he did say that that surprised me
because I don't wear fragrances that was
nice of them to say it was just the
pheromones just the musk just the moans
oh yeah the moans in the Musk
I don't know
there it is all right let's do our ads
we got a lot more to talk about actually
I never even talked about the main story
I went on such a tangent here
that um
we still need to read this article so
let's do the ads and then we'll continue
the Saga yeah Bobby's Bobby and me said
we were making colomba
called bird flu right
I mentioned it again on a podcast
recently so he's still waiting for that
call okay all right bird flu Oh people
are pointing
if you made a perfume you could call it
Ethan's Musk
Ethan musk Ethan's Musk
is that yeah Ethan's must like Elon Musk
I think it works better if my name is
because elon's musk would be a fire name
Klein Couture
Klein Couture anyway here uh thanks to
our sponsors
babble
yes sir yes sir
um if you're like me there's a foreign
language that you regret not learning in
school and it's never too late to start
with Babel Babel's a language learning
app that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions and thanks to Babel's
addictively fun and easy bite-sized
language lessons you can finally cross
learning that new language off your list
I love Babylon you know I throw it
around in there I always try to brush up
on my Spanish
because I live in California you know
muy bien that is not Spanish
that is yeah not that's not Spanish
but I feel you on that
but the the actual the Babel programming
is super fun like there's games that are
actually super fun
the programming it's it's you know
they're only 10 minute lessons so you
you once you get started you could be
having dabbling in real life
conversations
in as little as three weeks
other language learning apps use AI for
their lesson plans but Babel lessons
were created by over 150 language
experts and voiced by real native
speakers not computers
their teaching methods have been
scientifically proven to be effective
and with Babel you can choose from 14
different languages including Spanish
French Italian and German
uh plus Babel's speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and accent there's so many
ways to learn with Babel in addition to
lessons you can access podcasts Games
videos stories and even live classes
plus it comes with a 20-day money-back
guarantee that's a good deal right there
so start your language learning Journey
today I know Ian's been on there
learning um French man he's ready to
travel the to to France right uh yeah
again we damn you're really not [ __ ]
give me anything man like that was the
most unenthused we yet
most Mall
what's mom mean
all right let's see you got to get on
Babel because I said no not Mall oh
what's not mean it means no oh you just
put a little stink on the o yeah put a
little stank on it no
you want to impress you want if you want
to show the Babel people how good their
the app is or
uh leave
book okay okay all right thank you Ian
who's uh
hard at work over there on Babel
the man is basically a native speaker at
this point but
results I'm sure may vary and I have a
feeling yours are gonna vary towards
being way better
uh right now get up to 55 off your uh
subscription when you go to babel.com
h3tv that's babel.com h3tv for up to 55
off your subscription that's Babel
language for life and you get that 20
day money back guarantee so come on
let's get after it good offer 55 and a
20-day money-back guarantee
go thank you Babble thank you thank you
and finally you know him you love him
it's the greatest in the game it's hello
fresh let's go
that's right oh
[Music]
hellofresh is feeding fupa troopers
everywhere keeping us
nutritiously fed deliciously hooked up
and for Christ's sake we're learning our
way around the kitchen
and that's something tater tots will
never understand when you can cook a
meal
did no matter your gender that's gonna
help you
get laid
straight up
people love people that can cook
am I wrong no that's that's absolutely
it's the road to the heart they say yeah
they're true and look at these meals
they're so freaking delicious
uh with hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip the tricks through the trips to the
grocery store and count on hellofresh to
make home cooking fun easy and
affordable and that's why it's America's
number one meal kit you don't even have
to think about it dude you sure don't
you know how it works is they send you a
box with all this fresh pre-portioned
ingredients well
Yo which one is that damn that's a
hellofresh one it looks way too Gourmet
you didn't buy that from the store maybe
no sir 100 hello fresh baby is that a
three-star Michelin thing are you sure
that came in hellofresh that was
hellofresh
look at those grill marks you gotta take
my word for it I don't believe you man
what's in there like caviar
uh whatever they sent me
yeah three eggs
yeah uh
they send you a box with super fresh
pre-portioned ingredients you don't have
all this leftovers so you're not wasting
money on like 10 pounds of carrots
and uh they have this card that tells
you exactly how to cook it about the
food you're gonna learn a lot
about cooking and it's kind of a
foolproof way to just make a really
delicious healthy meal home cooked
uh listen guys if you have a packed
schedule this fall hellofresh has meals
covered with a weekly selection of 30
plus recipes and 70 plus convenience
items all delivered to your door
now more than ever we're all looking for
ways to save money in fact hellofresh is
25 less expensive than the take on and
it's even cheaper than grocery short
store shopping too
uh so go to hellofresh.com
h3tv65 and use the code H3 TV 65 for 65
off plus free shipping please wow that
is an insanely good offer and I just
want to mention I said it last week real
quick but my brother stayed with us for
two weeks and we needed to add another
portion it was super easy we did it on
the app and we had portion for three for
two weeks that's awesome you guys eat
that every night oh yeah every night wow
that's good right you feel like you're
getting good meals and yeah definitely
yeah better than going out that's
cheaper it definitely it's cheaper way
cheaper you know I feel like even when I
go out or order in the food so many
times it's just not that good you know
it's always disappointing
there it is
uh 65 off guys uh thank you thank you
hellofresh America's number one meal kit
God bless
oh
[Music]
okay let's go
okay hello
I actually have to pee again [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I'm gonna go for it because I chug those
fiber
those Metamucil drinks in the morning
like I'm gonna pee out your [ __ ] no I
don't have to be on my [ __ ] okay I'm
not taking a pause
somebody said I made the hell a fresh
quesadilla that'll blow Abe's burrito
out of the water whoa Nick
Nick
Nick whatever dude
why you gotta come for a b like uh your
opinion man yeah those are fighting
words
listen I didn't ask for this burrito it
just happened to me okay I didn't you
know wasn't planned
you can't compete with stuff like that
it just it happened organically what can
you do magic
Valerie says the H3 perfume should be
Pizza scented like the smell of a nice
authentic Italian pizza place with notes
of basil and fresh baked crust
I like it Valerie
not bad maybe we could do it like uh
fika fish scent oh that's interesting
I kind of like how we did the uh
butthole candy the butthole candle
before your fika fish perfume Vito Vito
I love you that'd be nice
you like that
remind you of home it's a good meme it's
nostalgia
yeah
uh can Ethan say he loves Arsenal so my
boyfriend can love him and not say he
doesn't like you
um Arsenal the uh the football team I'm
assuming that's a reference team
yeah I don't know if anybody uh are they
talking about the band Arsenal from uh
Rock of Ages the movie
what yeah Arsenal
hmm is that some deep cut reference I'm
not understanding nah she's the band in
the movie oh okay
okay very good very good hi guys it's my
24th birthday today love your videos
from England happy birthday happy
birthday oh because
happy birthday shout out England
where is Olivia's thank you for the
gifted drop from the spicy chip show oh
you say that or something her voice like
cracked didn't you thank you
it was really funny we'll have to hunt
that down right we'll have to pull up
yeah make a note my BFF just got married
and watched Friday's episode the morning
of her wedding and I got her to be fresh
wow she warmed up for a wedding with a
c-man interview huh
it's all that on Reddit actually I did
too yeah congrats to her Tampa Bay is
about to be slammed by a hurricane Ian
like it's 1921 wish me luck oh yeah what
the [ __ ] dude
stay safe
yo why they name hurricanes Ian like
that's just so basic clap those Chiefs
like they all have names like that no
they used to have cooler names like
Katrina is more interesting Sandy Sandy
yeah I mean yeah
I like I like the Navy game for a
tsunami or whatever yeah it's like you
really want to drown to a one-syllable
[ __ ] white man's name Eaton [ __ ] it
is too simple it has three letters I'm
gonna be two but it is powerful man
in in
here is a live reporting
yep interesting yeah did you make that
Amy no no that was on Reddit
I was like
that doesn't seem on Cam's level but I
like the joke
I mean Ian if this is one of these
really hard crazy like Katrina Styles
this could [ __ ] your name up for a long
time
thoughts I mean according to you it's
already the worst name ever okay so how
how much worse could it get right well
you don't want to be associated with
like thousands of people dying do you
because that's what you stand that's
that you know this is on you bro I think
you got to change your name yeah
I'll change it I'll change it to Andy or
something
hurricane Ethan no
not hurricane Ethan bro how could you do
this I can't believe you've done this
220 25 million deaths
what is this website hypothetical
hurricane right after what you
highlighted it says also caused 25. oh
my God Ethan what have you done 25
million people one hurricane why were
they all just laying in a ditch one bad
stream oh it's a there's some book
called hurricane Ethan apparently
because I just Googled hurricane Ethan
and clicked on the first link man I know
there's the name Ethan for me there's no
hurricane Abdullah but
did some other stuff probably who the
[ __ ] creates this website welcome to the
hypothetical hurricaneswiki a wiki-based
comprehensive database of hypothetical
tropical Cyclone articles that was
awesome man yeah look at this website
I've got one hurricane Dan kills
everybody on Earth well let's look it up
it's probably on here Wayne Dan death 6
billion
hurricane Dan 2016. Dan over Europe
death
how many deaths there you go a trillion
3.9 billion ah I was brought it up to
that nice work how's the hurricane kill
half of Earth hater ass hurricane that's
why it was a hurricane
did its job
yeah this website's Wild
well look up Ian then let's see because
this shit's real this isn't a
hypothetical
let's see first category is five wait I
think this is real this is the real one
yeah wait is this really what it has no
105 that seems more believable it's our
they're already counting death she
didn't even hit landforms predicting it
hasn't hit landfall in the states yet
but it's hit all kinds of islands and uh
said 9.7 billion in Damages
how do they know that it's a prediction
it's just probably a prediction they're
disgusting how is it a prediction like
literally they don't go predicted
they're like yo this is what happened
what if they're right you know
the hypothetical hurricane fandom Wiki
needs to pick a lane is this is this
like a fantasy thing or are we reporting
on real hurricanes like it's it's
creating a lot of confusion here sexual
fantasies well hurricane Ian uh good
luck out there in Florida man that's
scary hurricane Ian can they be no no
hurricane let's see where it is because
I let's see let's check the Doppler
hurricane Ian intensifies
she has still off
wait
is that what's just like effing up
Puerto Rico Puerto Rico Cuba looks like
it went right over
there's lots of people oh Ian dude what
are you doing we love Puerto well you
wouldn't want it to be like a [ __ ]
tornado when it has your name either
can't be too bad
that's a great Point love that isn't it
you want it to be a little bit
successful but not too crazy no like no
fatalities but maybe some property
damage right yeah well maybe a cup
fatalities a little bit of grit to it or
else it's not a dub yeah wow that's
gonna hit hurricane Ella Kane hurricane
love sounds like a shitty rapper
okay okay what the hell no not you love
just the name hurricane love I'm sure
you're a great rapper well anyway let's
move on uh it actually appears to be a
um
hurricane love
they kind of look like uh that's a band
yeah giving me Credence
they're the type of band that that claps
and says hey a lot during the chorus oh
it's very Lumineers hey ho yeah this is
like a hey ho band for sure all right
thank you everybody we're gonna move on
I mean look at that hat congratulations
on everybody's hurricane
we will be moving on now
peace and love
so back to dubrick actually I wanted to
see this Tick Tock is this this might be
an ad right I mean he's just holding up
a picture of doctor strange it's a new
doctor strange charger I got checks out
you put it on
look at that
whoa wow wireless charging oh that's
[ __ ] sick isn't that [ __ ] insane
look at this it's a new Doc it's okay
it's [ __ ] insane Ethan it's okay
that's kind of cool I don't know it's
all right it's cool it's cool I guess so
anyway David dobrik we established she
made a lot of money
insane what does Google say he's worth
or just even though that's just dumb
obviously but David dobrik net worth
let's see what did Google God say
25 million
pretty good okay dubrick I see you
pretty good
and let's not forget that little
[ __ ] Lottery he did with the puzzle
I think he cleaned up pretty fast on
that one
you remember that yeah of course yeah
anyway I'm still mad I didn't win so
anyway Jeff wittick knew risk of
excavator stunt don't blame me
Yeah the more I learn about how much
money he's made it is even more uh
incredible that he just didn't help Jeff
Moore David dobrik says he shouldn't be
held responsible for any injury suffered
by a YouTuber in a social media stunt
gone wrong claiming the guy knew what he
was signing up for
that can't be true
he knew he was signing up to get his
face smashed into the side of an
excavator
that was the plan the whole time your
honor
the influender the influencer just
responded to Jeff whitak's lawsuit
against him with David claiming Jeff
knowingly assumed the risks involved and
can't collect any damages
[Music]
Jesus
Jeff says uh when it was his turn David
started swinging him around too quickly
for abruptly slowing down
yeah there's not it's actually not that
much I'm surprised we don't even managed
to turn this into a segment
in his response to Jeff's suit David
claims whitak knew
how risky the sun was and he can't blame
David for his injuries David is asking
the judge to dismiss the complaint and
award nothing to Jeff good luck with
that
so I mean you being somewhat of an
expert in lawsuits at this point it's
almost like just automatic that people
motion to dismiss to nothing right
standard
yeah stupid but actually made a good
headline and uh we actually got to check
on David which was fun so
shout out to uh Jeff whittick for giving
us some content
that lawsuit
um
do you guys want to talk about the Adam
Levine
cheating updates because this thing went
deeper than I thought I thought it was
just one girl but apparently he was
[ __ ] everybody
it seems like he he liked James Charles
he was using social media as a dating
app
yeah
well they were all of age yeah I was
just saying the dating app part right
for you page and explore page dating
apps
yeah at a certain point when everybody
just kept going it was like
okay like what are you no one's coming
forward on like claims of abuse like
you're just you're just making his wife
I'm sure feel much worse she knows that
is interesting yeah and these girls knew
he was married yeah like hello he's
super famous well he's married he was
manipulating them allegedly telling them
that he's about to get a divorce which
is what all married guys say
yeah he was definitely using his power
in a in an unhealthy way but these girls
did know that he was
that is [ __ ] up to lie about that
that's the thing just don't cheat man
just just you know just get a divorce if
it's that big of a deal to you yeah and
don't cheat on Instagram especially if
you're an A-list celebrity
bro did you see Tana Mojo posted that he
had like unsent her a message because
she went to see if he had and when you
unsend something it'll say like accept
or decline and so there wasn't a message
but it said accept or decline and so he
that means that he reached out to Tana
Mojo three times about like the guys
that she hangs out with he was horny
posting like this he just have an app
that like texts every like blue check
woman on Instagram
amaranth said that I don't know if she
was just joking but she said that he was
in her DMS no way I mean if he's
messaging Tana I could see that like
holy [ __ ]
what's this guy have time to write music
I don't understand this guy's a
full-time job well have you heard their
music yeah I mean come on
I actually I'm not familiar with their
music at all I just know he has the
worst you know it without knowing it
it's inescapable
I think he has some of the worst tattoos
I've ever seen I don't know if we talked
about it
I think we've in the past mentioned that
like bro has no [ __ ] taste
California like why it looks like he
just it looks like he went to a tattoo
shop on Venice and just like took the
book and was like just give me
everything like just all like the
default tattoos right I'll take one of
each California those are like Grand
Theft Auto tattoos right yeah the thing
is like
why would you write California like
because it really mean that much to you
you know
Rose true love butterfly cherub Eagle
Eagle butterfly yeah flying it's just
like
[Laughter]
he's Jack though he looks good
I saw a tweet somebody said his tattoos
make him look like a Chipotle bag oh
yeah that's [ __ ] good oh the back
one's wild what
at least that one has some intricacy to
it it's still like a mermaid tattoo
again it's just like all of like the
most basic [ __ ] you could possibly get
it's true it is just a mermaid tattoo
that's interesting when you put it that
way
but at least you know it's like yes
Supreme underwear kind of a poser but
okay I'll let it pass
judging everything now he looks [ __ ]
good though
you know
he's in his 40s
he looks great
that's what I'm gonna look like in a
month
I'm doing the treadmill absolutely
absolutely man some guys you know
sex is just so important to them and I
I just can't understand that I don't
know maybe maybe I'm just built
differently
or maybe
I feel like when guys sleep around or
times in my life like in college when I
would like
have like a one night stand or something
which didn't happen a lot maybe once or
twice but when you go back and analyze
it it's always like you do it because
you're insecure and you want to validate
yourself that like somebody's willing to
like you I feel like that's more what
it's about because you can just go jerk
off bro if you really just need like
some release
yep
um I don't know well and isn't his wife
like a gorgeous like Victoria's Secret
model too yeah like he was lacking yeah
concerning Adam Levine
her name is the hottie
but yes oh yeah she's gorgeous she's
beautiful Bahari yeah I grew up the
hottie I literally just typed bahati I'm
sure I spelled it wrong
uh E8
so we said Affleck versus Levine we need
ela's take I mean she's gonna say half
Flex is worse wait Affleck didn't do it
he just made one cringy he wasn't no no
talking about the back tattoo oh yeah
Ben afflecks is that it has color in it
our Adam Levines are just black and
white right you know what I think that I
think that we might actually
have an interesting competition we
should ask her on Friday
okay make a note of that it's me yeah
bro why the [ __ ] can I not I brought
body Adam there's Adam Levine's wife I
was like why is it okay here we go here
we go
let's take a look at this bahati the
hottie
you know and I I feel so bad for the
women like
they sacrificed their body their youth
to give this [ __ ] ingrate children
and it doesn't affect him at all and he
just goes and [ __ ] cheats on her
and it's like damn bro
she you know
she put her body through a lot you know
so you could go [ __ ] some Instagram
models like damn come on that's all true
too but like the D you know not unusual
for some like rock star guy to cheat on
his wife obviously happens all the time
the aspect of the story that like pushes
it into
like something's wrong with him
territory is the whole
asking to name one of his children after
the mistress like that is such
a weird [ __ ] twist to the story that
I don't even know what to think is going
on with him Menace behavior that is that
is really crazy but do we know that he
didn't have like a arrangement with his
wife
we don't actually I mean I guess
possible there were photos paparazzi
photos of them smiling and laughing like
the day the allegations came out so
people are speculating that maybe they
just have an open relationship but why
else yeah but why else would he post
that cryptic cryptic of a message
what message did he his his like
response where he said I [ __ ] up
um I'm mending it with my family
oh
oh can you pull that up I didn't know he
made a statement this is so juicy gossip
guys
Adam Levine
um
talk about
it I tried to
wait I'm trying to get all the details
[ __ ] you have nothing
uh Jennifer hello H3 Squad thank you for
keeping us entertained love you guys
Lots serious message to my ex I hope
he's happy with his co-workers is that
another snarky X call out
I don't know how to interpret that but
shout out
oh Cameron Cameron came back he said
thank you for the shout out Abigail
loved it I was on the show Once for make
Ethan laugh and I shared a story of Abby
and I did that to make Ethan laugh I was
the guy who sold meat
oh I remember that the guy sells me
yeah I don't remember the details but I
definitely remember the meat salesman
aspect I do have on the meat shop yeah I
remember something about meat know your
way around some meat so here's what Adam
said a lot is being said about me right
now and I want to clear the air I used
poor judgment in speaking with anyone
other than my wife and any kind of
flirtatious matter I did not I did not
have an affair
nevertheless what how did he not have an
affair
he's well always saying they never had
sex I'm pretty sure the [ __ ] was
ready to name his kid after
that she says they were dating for like
a year
well he's denying it you bro I seen
those DMS you're the thirstiest man
alive he definitely [ __ ] her he's like
oh my God
you are so [ __ ] hot I can't believe
it didn't I even say that uh he said he
was like you look better in person he
said seeing you in person he did say
that all right well why why are you
lying bro why are you always lying
uh he uh used poor judgment I did not
have an affair nonetheless I crossed the
line during a regrettable period in my
life
in certain instances it became
inappropriate I have addressed that and
taken productive steps to remedy this
with my family you are such a Liars
bro why you even bother with this [ __ ]
it's such a lie
my wife and my family is all I care
about in this world
to be this naive and stupid enough to
risk the only thing that truly matters
to me was the greatest mistake I could
ever make
I will never make it again I take full
responsibility no you don't you lied I
must say that I've had some post-coital
regrets about that that is true
we will get through it and we will get
through it together so yeah it doesn't
sound like it sounds like she's pissed
[Music]
stop [ __ ] lying
it could be that she's just embarrassed
if they did have a really Arrangement
she's like don't I don't want anyone
knowing you're cheating on me it's
humiliating and I want the kids to know
certainly
no this isn't a real one maybe is it
yeah it's from this article yeah
you got a juicy DM
just look at the chat read this exchange
he said
he said of this girl [ __ ]
I do anything for
spiral face emoji for it I'd buy it a
steak dinner and whisper sweet nothings
into it
bro you are so embarrassing
it's uh it's like The cringiest Thirst
people you can imagine
what was this in reference to like her
booty or something yeah
dinner and whisper sweet nothings the
follow-up was I may need to see the
booty [ __ ]
that one
I haven't seen this other part of it I
love that I have not seen [ __ ] like that
seventh grade
nobody believes you dude anyway here
let's get into the juicy gossip here
there's now eight women saying that
and again like you said you know yeah
he's a cheater we know but he didn't he
didn't do any essay which is you know
good for him I guess that's kind of a
low bark
but no he sucks
but no essay so congratulations Adam
young women that Adam Levine cheated on
his pregnant wife and kids with I'm
biati and I'm biati's husband Adam
Instagram model summer stroke exposed
him first in a tick tock with now almost
30 million views I was having an affair
with the man this is the girl who the
the third spells came from this is what
kicked it all off you need to get in
that booty
Secret model
Adam and I were seeing each other for
about a year I was completely
manipulated I was under the impression
that their marriage was over she claims
they did physically cheat and text he
sent her
I mean I think the same seeing you in
person I was like I'm [ __ ]
I'm fit you are 50 times hotter in
person and so am I he says of himself
it was at this moment that he knew he
[ __ ] up
dude you're so sad
so sad to say that about yourself
yeah unlike them I'm 50 times grosser in
person so that's interesting how that
works
thank you Zach
seem to cooperate that number two is
another young woman he met on Instagram
Allison Rosa I guess if any other girls
have experienced this with him I think
they should post it because I feel
really bad for his wife and yep March
18th nice I shouldn't be talking to you
you know that right he says whoa
nice little manipulation there you're
writing this down in DMS how dumb can
you be
he's I think just like
personally I think when he was sending
these messages I think he
was doing something you think he was
beating off definitely he had poison he
was just poisoned he did again the
post-coin will regret you know I think
he really was I would say more of maybe
something like Coke or something to have
that gone God I think I think this dude
is super [ __ ] horned up yeah drugs
drugs it could be a good uh
equation here for this
nobody deserves it he knows he shouldn't
be talking to her third was his personal
yoga instructor Alana and this guy's
[ __ ] everybody naked and said that
she has the best ass in town then she
said when her boyfriend saw these texts
he broke her wrist and Adam dropped her
um can we I he he rushed over this oh
whoa and when I first saw that he's like
uh her boyfriend broke her wrist I says
sorry Jesus
that's a lot to gloss over
are you
is that true
I mean the yoga instructor boyfriend
broke her wrist
I can uh deep dive into that and then
he's like yo I'm out of here this
appeared and never helped next is
Fitness influencer Ashley Russell who he
at least asked if she was of consenting
age next is an Instagram model named
Marika who called him out and said dude
aren't you married and he said yes but
it's complicated and he might get away
proving that he misled these girls to
think his marriage by the way I love
dude this girl's such a queen look at
this message
he's horny posting and she just goes
dude aren't you like married
that's coin [ __ ] right there
yeah so his yoga instructor made an
Instagram post that said that he Adam
texted her saying I want to spend the
day with you naked her ex saw it got
jealous wanted to enrage broke her wrist
what and then Adam bailed
uh yeah you can't she can't teach yoga
with broken ribs I mean first of all
uh no that's [ __ ] crazy oh Jesus
Christ you got a crazy ass boyfriend
there
wow
men are crazy man I'm sorry ladies
wow what do we do about it
what are we what are we gonna do about
men wow without men what are we going to
do about men nothing and women be
shopping women shopping men be breaking
news
where would we be without men
they want to [ __ ] everything that moves
one time my yoga instructor
got her wrist broken when I tried to
[ __ ] her where would we be up yours
do you know who I am I'm Jordan Peterson
and I've got a little Hitler in my penis
[Music]
where would we be
there's a lot of Hitler in here
there's more than a bit there's more
than a bit of Hitler oh absolutely
then the Instagram model floodgates open
Tana Mojo exposi tried to DM her Alissa
Violet exposed that he tried to damn
girl and another woman Megan James
exposed that he tried to DM her
before I show you what Adam and his wife
have to say make sure you follow so you
finally know who the worst men and to
date in Hollywood are and request okay
there you go someone's compiled a list
the worst man to date in Hollywood
ladies and gentlemen
so watch out for them ladies
um
oh my God you guys this you know what's
funny about this young gravy sent this
to me we've been chatting because we're
homies now because we kissed
yeah
and um
well because we were role playing the uh
the
DMs
and he's like yo this dude James Joyce
Adam has nothing on him
and I read this and man it is a ride
this is from 1909 uh James James Joyce
is like a Irish
it's an author famous for this novel
Ulysses
um that
I'm actually surprised you didn't have
to read it in college for English
because it's like kind of a staple of
English Lit classes and everything
I missed that one but apparently he's a
he's a ditch that day he's a prominent
uh writer
uh thank you by the way Cameron Cameron
and ABIA
keep going back and forth there
God bless him
you guys doing memberships doing gifted
and thank you by the way welcome to all
the new members for the podcast we're at
this drop-in tomorrow
exclusive baby
hello all right guys you're gonna need
to buckle up for this because I'm
telling you this is some serious [ __ ]
now I didn't even know that people were
this
filthy back in 1909 man I thought people
were all buttoned up a little more you
know because
people have become a lot more sexually
expressive today where before
people were more in the closet I feel
like with their fetishes or sexual
orientation or whatever what have you
I never heard I never read anything
dirty this dirty in my life
because exactly hit me some with some
music Zach
to Nora
my sweet little whore-ish Nora
I did as you told me you dirty little
girl
and pulled myself off twice when I read
your letter he jerked off twice through
her letter
well I never heard it called pulled
myself off but I like that
I am delighted to see that you do like
being [ __ ] our sways
yes it's gonna come what does it mean to
be [ __ ] up so it's just hard
or it's a specific thing
[Music]
uh well he oh ass in that yeah and he
famously had like a uh
uh scat fetish my man famously well in
that novel
correct me I'm sure the chat will
correct me if I'm wrong because I
haven't actually read Ulysses because
usually you have to like take a course
to like read it it's one of those kind
of books it's very dense but I believe
it's in Ulysses it might be in one of
his other books there's an entire
chapter just in great detail describing
him taking a [ __ ]
that sounds like high literature to me
um oh yeah here here he actually found a
source for this um and litter this
literature subreddit
Ulysses
uh the first after the first two lines
it has it quoted from the book oh it is
in Ulysses there you go it says the
first description of pooping in
literature he says
so we all know about Joyce's sex
preferences and yeah we're getting to
that cutie so he wrote quietly he read
restraining himself the First Column ad
yielding but resisting began the second
Midway his last resistant yielding he
allowed his bowels to ease themselves
quietly as he read reading still
patiently
that slight constipation of yesterday
still quite gone
it's not that bad I I imagined worse
dropped a grumpy
all right back to this he says uh
I am delighted to see that you do like
being [ __ ] archways yes now I can
remember that night when I [ __ ] you
for so long backwards
it was the dirtiest [ __ ] I ever gave
you darling yes
my prick was stuck in you for hours
[ __ ] in and out under your upturned
rump
come
what Dan come
all right inappropriate
I'm gonna come I am not speaking chill
lips are sealed Dan come on you're
making this more Awkward come I'm gonna
step away
[Music]
I felt your Fat Sweaty buttocks under my
belly and saw your flushed face and mad
eyes
someone keep their eyes on Dan why do
you step away
hands up then
I'm away from the mic
at every [ __ ] I gave you your Shameless
tongue bursting out of your lips and if
I gave you a bigger stronger [ __ ] than
usual fat dirty farts came sputtering
out of your backside this is when it
gets off the rails like really gets off
the rails my seed is all over this place
stop thanks that's so [ __ ] gross
you had an ass full of farts that night
darling do not come I [ __ ] them out of
you big fat fellows long windy ones
quick little Merry cracks and a lot of
tiny little naughty farties ending in a
long gush from your hole
it is wonderful to [ __ ] a farting woman
when every [ __ ] drives one out of her
I think I would know Nora's farts
anywhere
I think I could pick her out in a room
full of farting women that's a that's a
that's a romantic image to be honest
it is a rather girlish noise not like
the wet windy fart which I imagine fat
wives have
it is sudden and dry and dirty like what
a bold girl would let off and fun in a
school dormitory at night
I hope Nora will let off no end of her
farts in my face
so that I may know their smell also
and that my friend is how you write a
love letter in 1909
[Applause]
well absolutely vile stuff man
it's history baby
guess so
there you have it people were wild as
hell back what an experience man
so crazy dude felt like satire no for
sure this is this guy's serious as a
fart [ __ ]
my favorite line is just it kind of just
comes out of nowhere and it's like you
had an ass full of farts that night
darling
and I [ __ ] them out of you big fat
fellows long windy ones quick little
Merry cracks and a lot of tiny naughty
parties ending and a long gush from your
hole
[Laughter]
but parties
oh God so there you go guys don't feel
embarrassed because you know what I mean
someone asked this is a good question is
this the first first leaked DM
interesting
[ __ ]
there it is uh somebody cast us all in
the office
let's see it should be interesting
I'm Michael Scott that I'm I'm fine with
that I accept that
so ela's not Holly how are you gonna do
that
she no she's her that's not right that's
Jan are heel is Holly to me yeah because
they ignored the relationship aspect
with a lot of these what Jan was like an
ice queen wouldn't she yeah that's a
dish to ELO that's right well she's also
Jan is also low-key at Queens sometimes
she's a boss and she's a big her
character that's her defining
characteristic I feel like
well I guess it depends on what era of
the show because they kind of her
character changes a lot when she becomes
a mom right she is very funny right to
me well anyway let's move on I like this
one I forget his name but I see that
David Wallace I'm just glad I'm not Toby
although I gotta say I don't think
Zach's Toby Zack is 100 not Toby I'm
Andy if anything no I like Andy I think
Andy he sings I like Andy comparison a
lot of movie references what do you
what's your problem with Andy comparison
nothing I said I'm Andy no I'm asking
Dan because Dan was against that
I think of Zach as another character
don't say it
who's the big guy's name Kevin you think
of him as Kevin you think I'm Kevin
he loves he loves Blackjack he's also a
rocker he's a he's in a band
and he's the wholesome lovable guy in
the office which is Kevin is kind of the
vibe I love who doesn't love Kevin oh
people are saying Zach is Creed that's
actually even more interesting I like
that I'll take that that's exactly
because Creed is extremely Joker brand
yeah actually that that yep Chad's got
it now I don't know who's Toby but Zach
is not Toby
at all yeah no no poor Toby no one even
wants to be Toby I think everyone in the
office is a mix of like two characters
like Dan to me is Toby and Oscar like
the smart guy and the guy that yeah we
did this once a long time ago and I got
Oscar I'd much rather take David Wallace
actually but yeah you'll have a bit of
that your gym okay
and Lena's uh again not hooking you up
with your wife this is not a
relationship that ended well for them I
think it's just vibes
what's wrong with Pam I think Lena has
Pam energy
you know yeah I know I see that
especially with a lot of people on
Reddit we're saying when she did the hot
chip challenge it was like when Pam
walked over the fire
in that episode if you guys oh
interesting okay also I oh what I'll
take either I like cam I like Karen look
she's a great character but you guys
need to end up married
just oh they did Cam so dirty I didn't
even see that I don't even remember this
character oh that is like the worst
character on the [ __ ] show that's
brutal dude whoever made this hates us
like this is not a this is about Ian the
Stanley is pretty funny I'm very much I
feel like I'm Kelly right oh yeah oh
totally you're totally Kelly
I get Aaron Vibes a little bit I'm just
happy enough smarter Aaron well hold on
let's do one at a time I'm on Olivia
you're definitely not her she's like a
dum-dum she's like a giant Bozo and
she's also just like always happy well
that's yeah you're like very bubbly
personality chipper yeah you're Kelly uh
I think I'm Kelly I agree Kelly yeah he
only has all the tea Kelly She's Got Tea
thank you thank you very much I don't
know this person hates you clearly I'm
just I'm just happy to be not forgotten
in this one
you know what that kind of like
something uh Gail is that his name Gail
I don't even remember that character it
sounds like something I kind of see it
because he this guy makes like
soundscapes and cam just is over there
like when have I ever made a sound oh
[ __ ] Zach someone said you're Meredith
I'm married
I love Meredith so I'll take it I think
cam is Creed in my opinion no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no creepy is
just like out there Creed's my favorite
character though see Creed's okay back
is [ __ ] Stanley I see that totally
Ian you should say oh yeah Ian is
totally Stanley he doesn't want to be
here he [ __ ] hates us
well or one could argue he's a good
worker and just does his job and
Stanley's not like see that I'm actually
thinking
um who's the dude who runs bare minimum
who's the dude who runs the warehouse
apparel yeah I think Ian's kind of more
Daryl energy yeah Daryl was good Daryl
was good yeah and then oh Sam Pam
connection is not bad
I think you might be more like her
though Sam
for whatever that is whatever that means
and then love got Creed
I don't think I'm fine with that I think
on this show I'm not created like from
what people know but I cannot resonate
with queer a lot
how is there no Toby or there's no is
that Creed is Jimmy Lee oh there you go
[ __ ] a really that's pretty good I
think Jimmy Lee is packer
oh that's actually could not be more
perfect Jimmy Lee and I do love Jimmy
yeah exactly
laughs
wait what was his name uh the henchman
how am I forget Dwight where's Dwight
who's Dwight oh there's not Dwight that
could be Dwight let's be honest
though as much as I love being Jim I do
think it's maybe a mix between gyms
maybe he's a little more boy yeah I mean
for [ __ ] like ab1 is toy for Halloween
so I mean yeah oh true you do have
Dwight energy in the best way possible
that's true yeah I think you are Dwight
engine
mostly Dwight
I think they got the gym thing because I
always look at the camera
kind of ripped off Jim on doing that
well there it is I can't say that this
is the best one but there's a decent
shot there were other ones on this I'm
just glad I'm not I'm not Toby that's
all I'm saying because I've gotten Toby
in the past which I get but I'd rather
be
I don't think there's a Toby in here
who's the real Toby Shredder
the funny thing is like
uh Paul lieberstein like Toby is okay he
was such a pivotal part of that show
like writing it like I think he was a
head writer on it he was yeah
all right there it is the office ladies
and gentlemen
it went a lot smoother than our stranger
things discussion
yeah
I don't know why we got so emotional
about that it was it was a big deal yeah
we have to
betray those people yeah we have to
dress up like it's the students yeah
this is by the way you guys know I'm
obsessed with these [ __ ] up audio
edits
a great one from Curb Your Enthusiasm
this one's great man so good
check it out
this is really a surprising way of doing
what is an Essence
they cut every single word that was
really bad this is really a surprising
way of doing what is in essence a
reunion show
wow yeah yeah you might be the worst one
yeah difficult to say goodbye to Laurie
Strode
this is really a surprising way of doing
what is in essence a reunion show man
this is uh
there it is uh so nobody is free of
horrible
[Music]
to revisit and go deeper
go deeper
hi I am Ethan and I am and the podcast
history after Dark
oh man
check this out shout out to the Iranians
who are fighting for freedom
actually amazing what's going on there I
saw this video pretty incredible
I wonder if they're gonna actually
achieve something over there that would
be in so nice for the world
and for them obviously check this video
out
[Applause]
Iranians fighting for women life liberty
taking the country back and scaring the
Islamic public guard off
[Applause]
all right
[Applause]
good
so legit so awesome
and I just these people are so brave
there's no due process in Iran they'll
just like kill you for well they killed
a girl for not wearing a hijab that's
how it all got kicked off yeah so
goddamn man hope they get their country
back
anywhere that has a morality police
probably
not the best place to live
yeah they have a
a sect of police literally called the
morality police
it's wild that's some dystopian [ __ ]
it's disgusting
so they hide behind religion and really
it's just you know they're supporting
their own agendas it has nothing to do
with religion it's actually against
Islamic principles to be forcing laws
like that on people especially with
violence
they're like enforcing what kind of laws
like I'm
oh there's not that's like not in the
well it's not Iran at all well I got
[ __ ] last time I said this but it's not
it's not clear you know some people
interpret it differently but a lot of
people like us Lena's family me we
believe that it just means a woman to
that the book asks that a woman dressed
modestly you know right yeah or some
people think it means just covering the
hair some people thinks it means
covering their whole face
but
yeah I mean that's a good point though
it's kind of interesting how
people always do that even America you
know these Christians they're like the
most intolerant bigoted uncharitable
people you know and it's the same thing
here man uh
you know
[ __ ]
there it is
godspeed Iran
let's go
let's do it
lebanon's not like that right you don't
have to wear a hijab no you don't have
to yeah lebanon's a lot more uh
open-minded for the most powerful and I
understand
I believe
correct me if I'm wrong chat I know you
will because you always do but I believe
it was only compulsory in Iran and
Afghanistan even in Saudi Arabia it was
until a few years ago but they removed
that now I think you know culturally
it's probably still expected that people
do there but um I believe Iran and
Afghanistan are the only two countries
that required it yeah and it's just
crazy that they literally killed someone
for not wearing one like [ __ ] me dude
there it is man I think the world would
be so much better off with the free Iran
so I'm loving that
um
do okay this story is so much fun you
guys you guys know the channel Dude
Perfect Right
everyone knows Dude Perfect Dude Perfect
trick shots you made a history video
about them a long time ago yeah
they every you know they do trick shots
they're like
for kids
but
their videos are cool I mean it's
impressive what they do
it's a little goofy
whenever they hit a trick shot they act
like we just won the World War II or
something I mean it's over the top but
it's for kids so I think they're
wholesome guys
uh for the most part I'm sorry can I
just clarify that the woman that was
killed she was wearing hijab she just
wasn't wearing it correctly damn that
didn't work yeah Jesus
sad yikes
[ __ ]
but yeah dude perfect what the [ __ ] are
they up to
yeah uh here they are just to give you
an idea
you know what that was very important
that was actually [ __ ] insane what
the [ __ ] was that for real aggressive in
the [ __ ] I used to see them do
hold on I gotta see that again that was
awesome
well like a loss over here seriously oh
whoa how many Orcs have you killed bro
what that was insane actually all right
all right we stand Dude Perfect here now
holy smokes how did he even do that
so let me show you their most popular
videos because that one's actually way
too cool
I'm not going to turn you guys against
him with that one
here this one a half a bill or 426
million views do literally bottle
flipping
Jesus
Second Story bounce back
let's see dude
that was perfect dude
[Music]
water books are dead we're done
they wear Bass Pro Shop hats
they're sponsored by them
oh is that right I yeah earlier when I
was looking at them or you guys know how
I feel about that hat
I don't see it looking in the sub in the
[ __ ] cool as hell whenever anybody
wears it all right I don't know sounded
like a half sender right now yeah for
real I think why because I don't like
yeah yeah half center right here you
know what I think we have them I know
these people never went fishing before
I'm done
why are they trying to act country like
I see people walk around Los Angeles
with Bass Pro Shop hats what do you
never jerk off your dog Ethan yeah
what's next you never finger your dog
[Laughter]
oh they have a partnership page yeah oh
yeah dude perfect they're big
ripping darts with Pro Shop hats on my
guy well that's cool if they sponsor you
actually loving that
yo give me some of these sponsors yeah
dude look at these holy [ __ ] I want some
Dr Pepper Chipotle I'm gonna send it
where's my Chipotle burrito like David
got
oh my God look at that list I know
um Walmart I definitely want Walmart
money Toyota
we are we are Walmart
anyway here uh let's just watch a little
bit more
and baseball
I'm bottle flipping yeah
I mean okay that I mean yeah yeah okay
cool
cool
dub
[Music]
he wasn't a bullseye but okay cool
sick
[Music]
here we go a tiny little bottle flip uh
dude
dude
uh yeah so
okay
very good so that's Dude Perfect
although I really want to find the one
where they all go nuclear when they do
something
you know what I mean
maybe this one let me look you got to
see the overreacting
[Music]
yeah this one has 323 million
dude I'm not seeing the overreacting man
where'd it go
these guys are playing it cool now
anyway whatever that's dude perfect for
you so the story is
that they are building a hundred million
dollar headquarters
how much space you need to flip a bottle
oh you found one oh this is my video I
made on them yeah this is a good one
we're Dude Perfect welcome to water
bottle flip Edition
[Music]
yeah that's what I was like that's not
impressive at all I guess they stepped
their [ __ ] up yeah
perfect country where did
Dude Perfect yeah it's like okay
not that impressive I don't care so I
don't think I've ever been that happy in
my life that's what I'm saying it's over
the top it's a good point
uh here but okay whatever enough
so dude perfect is launching their
hundred million dollar
a headquarter
it's a 330 foot Tower
giant building
here's a video announcement
oh Dan's got a dude perfect trick shot
oh okay
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll put on my bass pro shop after this
yeah go fishing bro now you're a full
Center dude I once caught a fish this
[ __ ] big man you wouldn't believe it
you jerked that dog off my friend pass
me that Coors there buck up fits the
background yeah
for example when I jerk off Donnie
Justice for Donnie in Iran
here's the video
my thing about this was so funny is like
there's no shot that they're building
this
a hundred million dollar
33 story dude perfect trick shot
superhero compound there is no shot we
live in a society
the future of Dude Perfect has a 330
foot Trick Shot Tower
that is embarrassing I'm sorry they take
it too far crazy mini golf
Trick Shot Town crazy mini golf yo mini
golf's nuts but what's crazy man yeah
[ __ ] I can only imagine this is gonna be
a car dealership in five years
a Dude Perfect Museum okay yeah we're
all lined up for that
you guys been around for five years
no they've been around for longer than
that haven't they it's two I thought
they were like a YouTube staple I don't
think they've been around that long
look I'm gonna be the odd man out here
I think this is going to be built
I I I'm with you dude there is no I
think [ __ ] I think there's some crazy
[ __ ] people with money like this that
will invest in this and they have [ __ ]
you money like a [ __ ] ton of it I think
this is going to be built think about it
I I think this is just a rebranded like
um mall like a big mall right which is a
perfect building it they're huge though
I mean it's that where is it gonna be
because these guys live in like Kansas
or something there you go cheap land
yeah no the article said uh they haven't
decided yet but they're looking at La
Atlanta and Dallas they don't even know
where they're gonna build it Dallas I
could see it well they're gonna shop it
around in L.A that'd be too much they're
not building that in La
cost like a billion dollars this is for
sure gonna be in Dallas if it's in La
I'm going
I'm gonna get a [ __ ] mean 330 foot
trick shot bottle flip [ __ ] I think
this is going to be built I really do
all right well let's see let's keep
looking uh the Dude Perfect museum two
acres of outdoor space yeah uh welcome
to it's called grass not that impressive
dude it's all over the place well done
anytime anyone buys proper
property okay it's grass who cares
um a merch store yo they've got a merch
store there
and restaurants
all right so let's watch the video I
know I'm being a hater ass [ __ ] I just
thought it was so funny because there's
no [ __ ] shot they're building this
[Music]
we can't play the music yeah just I just
played that
[Music]
is this dude like
this looks like a Tony Stark building
Avengers compound
you know what a b said and was very
accurate it was the uh it looks like the
meme of like this is what the future
would look like if uh if there were no
lawyers or whatever right
by the way we live in a society as far
as renderings go this said literally
nothing I mean
it I did they even show the inside of
the building barely
all it says all it says is here is merch
town
looks like a goddamn cruise ship with
that [ __ ] like merch down
I don't see it man let's do a pull I
want to know
what's the poll
uh if this is gonna get built or not
will it be built also they say a hundred
million if they're building in Dallas or
La this is going to cost way more than
100 million dollars
no you know
someone goes
congrats guys this is sick congrats on
what they didn't do anything
they just said they're going to do it
congratulate me I'm gonna build a one
billion dollar
fupa Law Center
let's do a poll you guys think they're
gonna build this [ __ ] Google says that
they are worth 50 million
that's not as halfway there but you get
some investor I I don't know I I've seen
crazier [ __ ] really like what
I don't know Museum of death like I
don't think it looks like that but just
like an idea like that you know
all right let's do a poll guys all right
I'm putting the pole in the chat you
think this is gonna get built
make sure you make sure we put it right
over Ethan's face I don't really want to
hey but I still don't get this but okay
will this ever be built I'm saying no no
[ __ ] way I'll bet you want to bet on
it Zach yeah
oh won't even let me vote it says I've
already participated oh oh because it's
set to it's on the Y one IP address per
vote
I don't want the Dude Perfect People
rigging the vote here
they do build it maybe you could ask if
three wing
yeah whoa
well 67 are saying this thing's never
going to get built and uh
a full third think it's happening though
that's pretty that's a substantial chunk
well we'll see you know [ __ ] prove me
wrong
uh the Dude Perfect facility guys where
you can do trick shots
I I totally see their the business model
too
100 million dollars what are the ring
what are like the Sonic rings that are
just magically floating there those are
for to do your trick shot through that's
right Sloan isn't some kind of trick
all right anyway shout out to uh
Overland
yes
oh they're hiring
yo they're hiring in San and Texas
they're looking for
designer
licensed architect
General application and client
development managers
cool
look at all these [ __ ] crusty old
[ __ ]
this state all these people are working
on this what is Overland oh they're
Architects until it gets hot in Texas
okay whatever l
listen I hope it gets built I'll go
there man
that's all I have to say about that
um also well I'm happy to announce that
we are also building our own
headquarters
I'm announcing that it's going to cost
[Music]
you know
100 billion that's the budget on this
one so I'll take your congratulations on
Twitter but here's our rendering
um 100 billion dollar HP podcast Tower
of tomorrow
it has three
biodomes
these are fully functional civilizations
this should house about uh three million
people
and uh just for scale here's the Dude
Perfect
here's the Dude Perfect compound just
for scale
so it's a whole it's a different level
and you know we're gonna make this
happen
there's actually also just shooting
crystals into space which uh podcast
colors you gotta let them know
that does something it just looks dope
yeah should I submit this as a job
application to that architecture
yeah please please
also guys if you're if there's any
investors in the audience let me know
we're going to need about the 100
billion
I could think of all the t-shirts we can
sell there dude there's going to be a
merch shop there
and uh a trick shot area
it's going to be 0.3 million dollars is
this in L.A this is this is on Mount
Everest actually yeah it's gonna be in
the Himalayas yeah yeah it's hard we're
not moving the mountain to L.A
oh there you go no I just talked to them
they said airlift sick oh cool some
cheap land out there I mean if we have
if we have enough money in Architects
maybe we could just shoot it into space
and
you know people can just
chill in low orbit yeah and travel would
be economical in terms of carpooling and
stuff like this I feel like this is like
a cocaine discussion
um
why'd you send me this
love oh this is kind of this is Mr Beast
he had he opened like a physical store
or a restaurant in this random mall and
just look how many people showed up
that's kind of why I think it would be
possible to build something like that
and okay well first of all I agree this
video is insane but Mr Beast is a entity
unto himself
I think they are look at their recent
videos they only got like three million
on them
oh yeah maybe maybe like beef
look at this [ __ ]
you guys don't greet me like this what
the hell
[Applause]
the live show better be like this you
guys understand
[Applause]
people are there for a burger yeah for
Mr Beast apparently a free Burger guys
okay times are tough
I sure are I can't believe it because
Jeffrey Star was at a mall in Michigan
and he shut down like three floors just
for him he was very popular yeah I don't
think so should we do something at a
mall and just see if we could shut it
down you think we could do that yeah
that's when you know you're famous you
shut down a mall I think it'd be
embarrassing I think no one would show
up no I mean us people would show but
could we shut that [ __ ] down Zach shuts
down when he does a show I think if you
and neela are there we can shut down
them all
should we try just for the Shelf disrupt
all business there
forever all day like Ace family
set up an H3 Lemonade Stand just give
out free yeah just give out something
free that's the cheapest possible thing
I can like yeah a glass of lemonade you
know get more reason to come out
there it is
there it is
and there it is
I wonder if they have any trick shot uh
spots in that mall
or merch stores
definitely merged stores there it is
foreign
we have more updates from significant
others telling their
their partners that they watch each
three
here's one from Pete
asked my boyfriend if five years his
opinion on H3 could be worse
she said what's your opinion on Ethan
the H3 podcast I listened to he said
Howard Stern wannabe knockoff
that's progress
I think that's progress could
potentially take that as a positive it's
certainly not meant to be one I think
but
it's better than uh fat you didn't say
I'm fat so it's good he's a good man you
got a good man there
he didn't call me fat as a keeper fat
ugly and stupid he's a good man uh
my man is not going to stop me from
watching H3 no matter how many times he
takes the remote for me
she asked him how do you feel about
Ethan Klein just wondering
oh [ __ ] is this one real he says he's a
fat boring slob who can't come up with
original content so he just gossips
about fake internet celebrities no one
cares about
first thing out of his mouth that yeah
you think it's fake it could be real I
mean if it's I'm gonna real I don't like
him I'm gonna say it
I think all of these are fake all of
them were like ever since we talked
about it once on the show and it started
the subreddit became flooded with these
yeah because they started asking their
significant others everyone wanted to
see what their boyfriend would say
I think the most of them are real I
think there must be even if it's fake
people do think that I see that comment
like 20 times totally yeah totally yeah
like if something doesn't really matter
if her boyfriend or significant other is
a fan of Joe Rogan then they hate me
they think I'm fat boring l loser
and I eat carbs what a [ __ ] idiot
I bet you eat carbs [ __ ]
so I think I think this is it I think
this is how
I've lost the war to have men as fans
the men hate me
but uh you know what I've always I've
always preferred the company of women
anyway so
I love our Queen
it would be nice to have men not hate me
maybe once I'm not fat though yeah
there's lots of men in the audience I
know I know I love we love our men out
there
but you guys I don't know if you've been
surprised to know this the majority of
our audience is women it's like 60 40. I
think that's a huge Flex I mean I
most creators aren't their audiences
predominantly male like most male
creators for sure yeah for sure you know
when we were doing h3h3 Productions it
was like 90 male 10 women oh wow and I
used to always hate that I was like man
how the [ __ ] am I alienating women so
bad with my content yeah
so I'm actually super I'm super stoked
about that can I can we show this is
this okay to show yes cool yeah show it
I just screenshotted this right now so
for anyone wondering this is uh where
the gender demographics
pan out obviously there was a huge shift
in demographic when uh
when uh for enemies came out I think it
actually was even further during the
Frenemies era it was like 70 30. yeah it
wasn't but now it's kind of like
balanced a little bit further back
because the views on Frenemies was so
high it was like skewing everything
but I think that's awesome and it what
it really tells me is that a lot of new
people came to the channel and they
liked the show I think we work really
hard and think about the show all the
time and making you know the best show
possible I don't think there's a show on
YouTube like it
come to join us and together we'll end
women too there's definitely nothing
like it there's nothing like it right
yeah not even close
we had meat in a grinder in front of
like or in a vice in front of three of
the other biggest creators on the
platform bro and it even really work
that's us baby that's how we do it
you're random ass [ __ ] it worked it
worked it worked it's supposed to be
yeah
yeah that was the point right yeah we're
friends I like them so it worked in that
room yeah
right
was there beef in a vice
our other social medias are even more
shifted to uh women oh my God 70 30 on
inside
that's we have lost the men have left me
and we do love our women though
a woman but genuinely like I do wonder
how can we
get some of those Fallen fans back
because
it's nice to see the show grow even
though I'm hap like we have a great
audience in size and everything it's
super sustainable
it is a little bit painful to see our
subs going down every month it's not
that big of a deal because I know the
fans here and they love the show
but it's the men the men are leaving in
droves they're living in droves what are
we gonna do about it where would we be
without men
you'd have the H3 podcast those soy
Cooks
yeah but like I was saying it just meant
that a lot of new people came and they
liked the show and that makes me super
happy
so I don't know
so if you guys have any ideas I mean uh
I tried the ice bath thing that didn't
work
well
do we know that it didn't work give it
some time oh how long do I gotta wait I
was in the ice bath it's supposed to
happen in worse than like instantly
maybe we need some girls in bikinis
walking around yeah
get the guys back dude
no most of those guys hate that too
actually
because they're like they're like
well just based off of how much more
yeah exactly what can I do to make you
guys Happy
poor that's what I that's what we see on
Twitch all the time it's like literally
to to these young men a girl in a bikini
is apparently like Kryptonite oh and
they like hate uh only fans models
mm-hmm
you know it's kind of interesting things
are worse than I thought because it's
like you can't have both
either you hate women
or you respect women and then you lose
all your men fans isn't that crazy
I mean shout out by the way to the 40
man out there you guys are [ __ ] dudes
rock yeah you never forget the dude's
[ __ ] rock though you guys are the
good ones Dude Perfect
You're the good one
but that's so interesting when you be
like yo I think essay is bad Earl the
dudes are like ah [ __ ] this [ __ ]
crash loser fat Jew right
but I get that as much as fat you'd be
unsurprised you know
people are saying get jacked I think
that honestly might work you know
it's weird based off of what I mean
this whole this whole tater tot
generation they they hate women bikinis
they love shirtless muscular men
uh they hate only fans models but make
all their money off of working with them
apparently it's just there's there's a
lot of contradictions there that I have
a hard time understanding yeah what
fousey I felt gay right I felt that no
like that just based on what they said
that's why I think that's my favorite
song but yo when we do the sound bite
Olympics at the end of the year I think
that one's coming hard that's your top
Contender I think so I just love it it
makes me laugh every single time man I
love that one but I feel like Bobby
might take it you think yeah Bobby's a
strong competitor for sure
[ __ ]
anyway I'm gonna I'm seriously gonna
start thinking about how can I get men
back without just thinking that women
are second-class citizens
it's a tough tightrope to walk it really
is man
let's do a woman tier list and just
judge them off their legs
I think so too I think that that is yeah
people love that yeah that'll bring in
the others would you hit it yeah oh yeah
is she a smoke show or not you guys
remember when all the YouTubers doing uh
smash or passed on famous YouTube women
like how [ __ ] up was that that was
crazy they did it about Ela all the time
it's like dude that is so disgusting
so objectifying
so Wednesday
yeah yeah
well we could do faster past guys
Edition nobody's done that I think that
picture pass like sure let me see this
dude [ __ ] or he doesn't [ __ ] but like
imagine saying about like a lot of these
guys I knew so imagine being like yo Ela
from H3 I'd smash it's like bro what is
what we're saying
and I wasn't offended it was just gross
yeah it was a super popular trend on
YouTube
even back then I was pretty aware that
that was disgusting before my uh before
I took my woke pills
everybody's their walk pills everybody's
uh saying that Markiplier did a smash or
pass on Pokemon that was awesome I gotta
say that was super funny he did that
recently I thought it was very funny
it's one of those ideas that's so good
I'm angry I didn't think about it right
such a good idea
yeah but what do you guys think of doing
a smash or pass on like uh animals
um it's a little weird that's kind of
weird yeah I don't know about that but
like goats smash or pets yeah
um by the way I will remind you Mitzvah
number 26 says do not
fornicate with a beast
hey it's a Mitzvah did you [ __ ] a goat
today hey you Mr mitzvah
the Jews did you [ __ ] your dad today hey
mitzvah
it's interesting
uh here's another one uh on the topic of
texting our boyfriends what the [ __ ] is
happening on Isha right now is that
young gravy yes God I wish that was me
which one either so there's a based
boyfriend there you go
about that
oh here's another good one babe what's
your opinion on H3 huge hands
that's real for sure yeah these are very
real I think they're real I do like if
he's a fan yeah and they're doing it for
the meme I think it's real I don't know
why you guys are hating
I choose to believe these are real
you know what could make me uh more guys
watch do I mean um I feel like
milk boys there's got to be like 90 95
men 100 dude or a hundred percent I
think if I jerk off my dog and tell
anecdote about that could help oh
interesting jerk off Donnie
I mean apparently that's not a problem
for them I'm just spitting facts you
know
uh here's another one hey what do you
think about me listening to the H3
podcast I think Dan is your secret
boyfriend that you hide inside your
phone that one's fake
I'll just be your secret lover
how do you feel about Ethan Klein for
research purpose be honest piece of [ __ ]
mainstream liberal profiteering off of
distractions from actual issues by using
the naivety of this generation that's
real bro and this man definitely listens
to Jordan Peterson
even hit you with the umlaut over the
eye and a little accent I'm really
interested about Robbie's contact photo
yeah what's going on here is he lifting
up his shirt his full name right Robbie
Callan
Rabbi Rabbi Robbie your name's a rabbi
that's how you spell rabbi I know and
I'm saying it says Rabbi Colin the hell
of a name be an inside joke
right it could be yeah so there you go
uh this one's real come on at least he
called you mainstream he called you
famous yes okay I'd like that too okay
I'm feeling that I'm liking that for
sure
I'm profiteering off of distractions
hmm
I wonder what I wonder what he thinks
the real issues yeah what are the real
issues we'd like to drill down into that
a little bit covet is fake
yeah what do you throw mermaid being
non-white okay this one may not be real
uh
this one okay this one I'm questioning
but tell me what you guys think what do
you think about H3 fell off big fat fat
man bad Andrew Tate is my jebus tater
tot Tater thought
Jesus Christ seems super real
I love big fat
man big fat fell off big fat give you a
big fat kiss
on a tree are both way too cringe to
listen to for more than like two seconds
just angry
angry you're only two seconds two
seconds
there's so many of these what is your
opinion about youth information a true
alpha male that's what I'm talking about
thank you someone who gets it that's
black for the real ones are you telling
me that this is impossible that one girl
asked her boyfriend and he said I'm an
alpha male that's so far outside the
realm of possibilities too please clap
come on dude please clap
there's a lot of these [ __ ]
more than I anticipated to be honest
this is what I'm saying
this is flood of
very real messages flap oh you know what
we should do next
um we should do the
the Howie
Mandel meme history hostage conspiracy
of Summer 2020. wow
this I'm very excited about
we didn't have time for it on Friday so
um we're gonna do it today
uh I'm gonna go to the bathroom because
this is gonna take a minute I got a
piece so I guess maybe it's the is that
that Subs up because I just crushed this
whole bottle all right I'll be right
back again guys sorry
okay
okay
[Music]
so yeah actually some setup Olivia was
telling me about this Ajo conspiracy and
I wasn't aware and I don't think anyone
else really was in the office and we
thought it might be a fun little segment
where Olivia explained some meme history
so this is the great Howie Mandel
hostage conspiracy yeah I also learned
this morning that a lot of people in
this office have never heard of put
Lovato
anyone is it related to Demi Lovato well
it is but if you know who poops
Olivia I told you I didn't know what it
is but is poop from American Horror
Story no
no no no no no no don't worry I have
that that segment is all it's all ready
and ready to go nice so
okay well this Howie Mandel how hostage
conspiracy happened during the pandemic
and it was one of my favorite memes
happening at the time
find out more when Ethan gets back from
the back yeah absolutely the chat
definitely knows what's going on with
poot I've seen a lot of poot we love
poot a little poot in the chat I left
that yogurt store and didn't get the
yogurt that I wanted
a bad time the rest of the weekend
and then I had a hard time the rest of
the weekend
[Music]
my wife went out for yogurt without me
and then I had a hard time the rest of
the weekend Zach when's your show again
oh thank you Abe thank you for that
layup uh Zach Lewis live with the
Troubadour January 13th wow at the the
famous Troubadour in West Hollywood
California Miss Troubadour yes wow
famous place that's a legendary venue
with a whole lot of history in those
walls I'll tell you right damn wow only
the best musicians play there I heard
that's right thank you Olivia for that
so if you want tickets just Google Zach
Lewis Troubadour it's unbelievable to me
that you will be sharing the same stage
that John Fogerty was on just a few
short years ago love it thank you
honoring the history of CCR so if you
want to come see me get cursed
exactly was live with the trip you think
some of the curse like rubbed off and
still there because this was like this
was like
this was over five years ago you think
it's been cleansed by now hopefully
there's like a buffer period you know I
feel like you gotta like assume the
curse because I mean there's people in
there every night right right well I'm
gonna bring extra strings because I feel
like that's the biggest curse is popping
a string on stage so
somebody just said Dan in the thread
with the rabbi message guy his
girlfriend said that he was a hard-line
communist he's not a Jordan Peterson fan
oh so it's the other direction
so he's distracting from the real issues
like
[Laughter]
thank you excuse me for summing up
summing it up there I was looking at
your computer what was that crazy Spike
on the viewership
what are you talking about is that just
a bug oh it does that all the time it it
just disappeared I don't know why it
does that
um all right guys
this is gonna be fun Olivia thank you
for putting this together such a good
idea actually
and if you guys have suggestions for
mumar and meme history love to hear them
now who was there during the Great Howie
Mandel hostage of Summer 22. you
witnessed that Olivia did anyone else
I did oh you were there cam
do you remember where you were like 9
11. uh I do yeah I was in my room on
lockdown
that's it
you remember where you were in that day
absolutely where were you on all of the
days I was in my parents house there it
is just like 911 where were you on 911 I
was a baby
oh yeah
what a communion Alibi yeah would you
happen to be in a little baby I was a
little baby on a plane
okay
where were you Ethan yeah
on 9 11. you were also on the planet
were you one of those dancing Israelis I
was on an airplane
I was planting uh planned detonations
in New York
all right so guys during the summer of
2020 Howie Mandel
made his Tick Tock debut and now we all
know him as the meme god king of tick
tock that he is today what do we do
about it but at the time he was very
much new to the game
in fact the very first Tick Tock he
posted was so bizarre
it caught the attention of a lot of
people on
Tick Tock here is the very first
Howie Mendel hi everybody Howie man
Tick Tock um
let's take a look
Andel here creativity in just under a
minute just take a regular shopping bag
and all you need is a pencil and a pair
of scissors if you just take the
shopping bag and you clip the two
corners off that side and that side
and you just take the the the pencil and
on the front I write shoe
I don't know if you can see it
stop
then I don't can you see it it says shoe
stuff shoe stuff then you created a bag
where you could put all your shoe stuff
and it's easy to reach into like you go
oh where's my extra laces or where's uh
some stuff for my shoes that's what that
is
keep [ __ ] joining in for other craft
ideas
now obviously it's pretty zany right I'm
actually surprisingly like
youthful comedy style yeah kind of like
anti-humor yeah yeah yeah I mean coming
oh I mean I'm impressed you know it's
zany
it's a little late on that type of
Comedy I feel like he's like five to ten
years late right style
it was like a little bit unclear as to
whether or not he was really trying to
give people advice or if
um he was being ironic in a bit yeah
yeah I would I would uh urge him if I
were there at the time to go a little
more with it more which he does you'll
see yeah what do you feel if you had to
criticize this down what would you say
uh to Howard oh
oh I I enjoyed it yeah you liked it I I
thought that was pretty funny
well the Zoomers weren't ready because
um people started freaking out as you
can see the top comments and there's
about a lot of views it has a million
likes blink twice if you need help okay
seriously this is kind of suspicious
this is a cry for help
I feel like he's in danger because he's
stuttering and more shaky and calm
because usually around people show I
have I'm sorry Jesus couldn't read that
for real
Howie do you need help so
this kicked off massive speculation now
people are wondering
is this a cry for help like Britney
Spears on Instagram
one of the first viral videos responses
a girl named baldy yaddy this video has
24 million views my goodness she breaks
down all the clues you guys I think that
Howie Manda and that original Howie this
might sound crazy but in a recent Tick
Tock this is very compelling stuff from
uh very smart and talented young lady
here miss baldy you guys I think that
Miss baldy just miss baldy Audi Miss
baldy is that what she calls herself no
her her username is Baldi Yadi yeah so I
called her Miss body you guys I think
that you just you put a little respect
on her yeah absolutely got it sorry
about that
sorry I'm uh
just a [ __ ]
I ruin every joke
all their
crazy but in a recent Tick Tock video
Howie Mandel took out a random paper bag
and labeled it shoe stuff essentially
making a DIY project but this video is
full of secret messages just in case he
is actually being held captive please
signal Bruce's video comment follow do
whatever you can you can see in this
video that he's wearing a lifeguard
hoodie and on that hoodie it gives away
where he lives Santa Monica but also in
this video I know he doesn't live in
Santa Monica you very I think publicly
lives if you wear a shirt that has the
name of a place on it you you live there
that's so funny but I'm pretty sure
she's not serious although she seems so
serious in it so she's just Mega Talent
yeah yeah
so the letters SOS in a triangle just
look at this clip
and shoe stuff shoe stuff
SOS it's a signal that you are in
extreme danger just in case you missed
it let me replay it for you
it says shoe stuff
look at this video you can also notice
that the S's look like fives look two
fives and two fives make 55. if you dial
the number 55 it takes you directly to
the police it shows that you're being
held captive or that there's an intruder
in your house yeah that's not true is it
yeah 55
since when we've never heard that in my
life
that's [ __ ] in part two he spells
out the letter help you guys I think the
999 an emergency but can't speak press
five five and they can track where
you're calling from using this new
technology say that again if you call
999 but you can't speak and you press
five five they can track where you are
calling from by using new tech I have to
dial 999 what the [ __ ] is 999
fullfact.org
I never heard of that cross check that
on the hypothetical hurricane well let
me just call him that's accurate
information just call 999.
bathroom stall
I didn't know if it was real or not for
a good time called night did I call 999
no no no I think 999 is is 9-1-1 in
another country I don't think this
applies in America we have 9-1-1 calling
999. it has to work hold on I'm calling
service you're attempting to you oh
people are saying it's in England or is
unavailable there's no contact customer
yeah no 999 is the emergency number in
the UK
yeah where how he lives right
in the city of Santa Monica on the uh on
the British Coast right yeah so there
you go five five nine nine nine whatever
it is I think that's enough of a clue in
Britain if you dial 999 and then five
five you're in trouble Howie he had five
five nailed it now wait the s's are
fives but they're also s's for the SOS
exactly
I feel like you kind of have to
choose a language I don't know no no no
she's right no how is that there's
another one uh hi everybody another
person who's seeing the obvious cries
for help this one also has a tremendous
amount of views
uh with 830 000 likes
Howie Mandel here watch this and tell me
he doesn't need
hangman down there I don't think people
are joking
two corners on that side and that side
and you just take the the pencil and on
the front I write
hue
I don't know if you can see it just
watching the video again
stop
and it's easy to reach
okay
we've got it super scene by people oh
just because she she's big so this whole
these videos going viral there's a lot
of them this caused an insane viral
storm for Howie
forcing him to post a video assuring the
public that he was totally fine but in
this video his frantic movements and the
way he delivered it made everything
worse and deepened the conspiracies so
Howie uh made everything worse of course
here is hell no worse here is Howie
damaging everything
here's how we
attempting to debunk these rumors it's
damaging everything
hello people of tick tock
I'm okay I have not been kidnapped thank
you all for worrying there is no sign
and what the [ __ ] is this shirt he's
wearing holy [ __ ] like the most cryptic
[ __ ] up it's probably doing on purpose
they're like 90 codes in there can't you
see yeah
intelligence is the ability to adapt to
language
I read SOS when I read that those are
the coordinates for the Bermuda Triangle
I don't know what you're talking about
in this video nothing to figure out
except listen to what I'm saying I'm
fine
this is crazy
and if somebody was making me do this
what are the instructions
to do this
I'm fine people hello I'm not buying it
before free Howie I'm growing my hair
back people before I was like this is
just a silly goof now I'm worried I'm
worried too one of the top comments on
that video was didn't anybody else hear
the shh after he said hello people of
tick tock listen very carefully no way
hello people of tick tock and there's a
shirt can you turn it up for me a little
bit Yeah okay here we go listen
carefully guys it's interesting hello
people
oh
my God I heard it correct me if I'm
wrong but this also was happening around
the same time as free Brittany too right
so that that fervor was in the air I
think so yeah yeah so that they just
assumed every hostage was the A-list
celebrity yeah by the way the comments
section has been nuked on this video
like they don't want the truth getting
out brother everything only has like 10
likes
so Howie has made everything worse
and I'm actually word firm now
uh the public wasn't ready to drop it
so they continued to dissect more of his
videos
here is
some of his secret messages
deeper analysis by uh
Miss uh Baldi there
let's see what she had to say about that
I think Howie Mandela is being held
captive again these are my opinions and
not actual facts the only way I feel
like I can help him is by making videos
so if you can comment and follow that
would really help lose the algorithm
let's get started in this video behind
me Howie Mandela is trying to make a
petition so that 2020 can end early in
the caption he writes the date 8 14 20.
now this might sound crazy but if you
plug that into the alphabet makes the
letters h n and T otherwise known as a
hostage negotiation team now as if this
was not enough watch this portion of the
video
okay everybody this is my new tick tock
Howie says hello everybody this is my
new Tick Tock but when he looks up and
the brim of the Hat you can see the
numbers one three two dash zero in
police code this means armed Intruder
and then how he posted this video using
a number two pencil that's yellow how he
writes a letter this song playing in the
background
ah I send the SOS to the world that is
fair part three will blow your mind here
is part two as to why I think Diamond
Doll is being held captive
there you go by the way this video has
half a million likes so
read the visit and go deeper so
obviously it's credible lots of intrigue
um
this girl even got in contact with
Howie's children
to make sure he was okay here is part
nine so earlier
we had nothing to do we're milking the
[ __ ] out of this that's pandemic for you
by the way six hundred thousand on this
so these parts only got more popular as
they went on yeah Instagram live with
Howie's son and daughter here's a
screenshot to prove that it actually
happened and they both said that Howie
is not in danger they all claim that all
the hints that Howie has been throwing
on Tick Tock and Twitter were just jokes
and that it was a sense of humor but
once I let my followers know that they
all still don't believe it mainly
because of Howie's recent Tick Tock
video I recently commented on Howie's
Tick Tock and set do a dance by the
staircase if you need help it was a top
comment and how he did exactly that now
if this wasn't enough Howie also took
this video with the inverted filter on
and many people are speculating that the
message in this video is actually the
opposite now I don't really believe this
but if you've watched Parts one through
eight you would understand that there
are way too many hints for this all just
to be a joke but you know what there is
only one way to find out if Howie is
okay or not it's for David dobrik to
release the screenshot of the messages
that Howie has been sent ending David if
we get this this can actually prove if
we are correct or wrong please spam
David dobrik's at this is still out of
control what the [ __ ]
so funny
so there you go the joke has
unfortunately died down how he is okay I
have proof I mean the prolapse is proof
enough
but he has actually uh successfully
rebranded himself as the prolapse Howie
so you know what if
go ahead no he was supposed to come on
the show the other day and he
mysteriously wasn't able to
and to add on to that what if the
prolapse was a cry for help right it
kind of makes more sense than actually
just posting that the what about that he
has a prolapse who's posting that video
maybe he's a call for help who's Neil
for real
the whole time
I don't know I've been texting with them
guys maybe it's not him though maybe
it's Neil the
the last thing he drives for me
is
um
he said is him apologizing that he can't
come to make it to the podcast because
Neil is holding him hostage in his in
his prolapse the only Neil he follows
Neil Sean from Journey so Neil Shawn
holding him hostile that is number one
so Don't Stop Believing yes
um prolapse in the sky keeps on turning
well that's about it that's all I've got
here today how long we've been going
it's about three are we uh two and a
half
so
um let's see tomorrow is the very first
episode of just three thin
just three things I don't know okay
I mean I'm open to names I like Ethan
Unleashed or Ethan yeah I like Ethan
Unchained yeah
hmm it's a little too similar to off the
rails
Unchained off the rails
what if we called it bomb the dot dot
dot yeah honey good people are saying
they
they like the name but the one that you
just threw out just three thin just
three thin absolutely I like bomb the
dot dot dot I I don't care for that one
yes so thank you Miami Boys Choir why is
everyone spamming Miami Boys Choir what
about is that the suggestion for the
name I certainly don't hate it it's a
little unexpected what about the bomb
podcast okay I think I know the bomb
like that
is the Miami Boys Choir that thing
that's been blowing up on Tick Tock of
all the uh
the Jewish boys singing
um I don't know some song yeah I think
it is I don't know if it would get
claimed but I'll show you guys show me
boys choir it sounds like an anime
opening in Hebrew I believe
oh yeah I see there's a bunch of we'll
look into it maybe we'll talk about it
on Wednesday yeah but regardless
um
thank you and welcome all the new
members I'm excited for you guys to see
the first ever members only uh podcast
tomorrow we'll upload it in the morning
I guess I don't know like 10. shitload
of new member sign ups today by the way
well that's great welcome everyone very
happy to have you here
and I look forward to the feedback I
don't know what time should we upload it
just in the morning or 10 or something I
don't know can you schedule a members
post
um I don't know about that I think those
are like distinct settings I could check
let's just post it when I wake up or
whenever you wake up just right pop it
up for members okay
yeah okay thank you everybody for your
wonderful support such a treat have an
awesome fans UH 60 women
you know shout out to the ladies
Queens
it ain't no sausage fest in here no sir
people kill for this ratio
that's what I'm saying I mean clubs do
exactly
it's me popping off at the H3 live show
oh damn
interesting
just saying just saying
um all right so on Wednesday we are
having any special plans on Wednesday
uh let me remind myself oh well the
special plan is that the tickets go on
sale right and all the details of where
when how why all that I guess on it's on
a Thursday that we're having liver King
it's gonna be really cool by the way
thank you Straw Hat Ichigo think of the
gifted
hello uh they asked if there's going to
be updated merch with the new crew we're
gonna do a Christmas drop
that's going to go to
um all the crew the the the prophets
reminding whatever we have a very cool
thing that I probably can't talk about
yet you can merchwise
is it not sure I think it's sure I just
I don't know if it's like official
official I think it's official right or
Sam's not here but yeah no you could
talk about it we're doing
a second edition of the trading cards
and brand new art brand new art Cam's
putting in a lot of work on that so is
Sam and um there's gonna be some special
bonuses in this one right cam I believe
so there's like rare there's like rare
cards that will only be in certain packs
and stuff like yeah and foil cards and
stuff like that um should I can give
away what's the rarest one right I mean
who cares we gotta we need I think we
need to pick out some kind of prize you
get if you pulled the rare one but
there'll be a certain small percentage
of lucky people that will pull the
coveted golden prolapse
Nails prolapse and uh golden and gold
you'll need to stick your hand in there
to retrieve your prize yep
that'd be fun maybe there's just one
golden prolapse and we fly them out and
they have to go elbow oh like uh Willy
Wonka style yeah
elbow deep to pull out whatever it is
cool you could like do a flip by the
front door and greet them like Willy
Wonka
shout outs to rap trading too he's great
to work with shout out rap trading
that's a great product man the man when
people are asking what time on Wednesday
um they're gonna go live uh right when
we go live on the show basically so and
when we when we go live on the show
we'll announce all the details we'll
tell you where you can buy tickets and
yeah it's going to be password protected
for members so um we'll explain how you
will receive that password as a member
uh on Wednesday and you will be able to
use that to get first dibs on the
tickets
yeah anything else
um
the prolapse Factory
fly them out for the live show the
golden prolapse that's not a bad idea
although oh yeah we the the cards will
come out before the live show
that could be fun to do for one prolapse
winner oh interesting right yeah they
could be part of the show right
we can make like a fake I would love to
make a fake realistic prolapse that's
all gooey and red and [ __ ] oh God and
they have to put their hand in and grab
the prize
whatever it is maybe inside the prolapse
is just a
statuette of a prolapse just more
prolapse
you know
yo should we get Hunger ffs there
that'd be [ __ ] interesting what's
that he's uh part of like fist Fest oh
no no this shit's gnarly there's this
guy I know his name is hunger FFF stands
for fist [ __ ] right of course I mean
he's a he's a gay porn star but his
specialty
is in what's called and guys I'm just
going to tell you right now
if you're sensitive just turn off the
show because warning this is what it's
going to end now and uh there's you're
about to hear things you can't ever
forget oh boy
yeah so his specialty
is that he loves getting fisted
but he takes he can take
he can take loads objects sizes that
were before unimaginable
and his specialty as he prolapses
he can control his prolapse and it's got
he's worked on it has gotten so long
it's actually a 16 inch prolapse and he
refers to it as his ass me yeah yeah
and so you can actually find pictures I
saw it for the first time this morning
Zach sent me a picture it is really
[ __ ] gnarly man oh you don't say it's
like you're it's jaw-dropping like
you've never seen anything how do I find
a photo just type hunger FF prolapse
he's on oh Google he's got a Twitter too
yeah he's no he's a big guy what's
interesting is he's that I heard him on
the radio and I didn't expect he's very
handsome he's super fit good looking
dude yeah okay definitely a bear for
sure
okay but describe it to us Olivia as you
see it it's pretty good
it's pretty good oh it's pretty good is
he it's okay she got it
hunger FF one word
yeah I'd have to go on Twitter
I saw it it's on Google there's plenty
go ahead and describe it
it's not the reflection of love screen
isn't it it's like that's like a yam
like a sweet potato it looks like a
Christmas ham
yes eating it no yeah so that's what
they get into is that I guess other
people who are in the fisting like
playing with his ass meat
so they'll suck it they'll eat it oh
whatever
he's like he's like the legend of the
fisting Community you're right he's like
he's the uh and well earned may I say
it's incredible what he's achieved back
there yeah and Ethan and I were talking
like I I we're like how does this guy
not get
an infection or something that could get
him ill and he told me something
interesting yeah actually because I was
wondering and I'm sure I think a lot of
people wanted us we all get like
butthole Cuts or fissures or whatever
or sometimes you wipe too hard and your
butthole bleeds a little bit and I
always wonder how is it that you don't
get infections there like I've never
gotten infection on my butthole
right Dan
you're asking me if you've ever had them
you wondered that I mean yeah no I I
guess I've wondered I don't know if I've
specifically wondered it but it is yeah
well now you can't think about it it's
right yeah now that you're bringing it
up yeah
so the skin that makes up the butthole
and the butthole lining is very
different from the skin
that's on our skin and
um it's very hard for that skin to get
infected because oh I remember now
because it's so flush with blood there's
so much circulation going on and there's
tons of like red and white blood cells
there so whenever there's any bacteria
or stuff it's quickly uh cleaned up by
the body brought these on high alert
there's so much blood coursing through
that membrane okay so it's actually
quite difficult to get an infection on
your uh in your butthole well fantastic
I don't understand is how is it healthy
for a person to have their anus stick
out to 16 inches from their body I don't
think anyone's claiming it's health I
don't think it's healthy he just claims
it he's just not going to get how is
that yeah like like deadly though like
like how does this gentleman get like a
a prostate exam one day easily he pulls
it out yeah yeah easier than most
yeah it seems that he's getting a
prostate exam pretty much every week I
think he can get his pulse checked
through his ass man he feels hard oh God
stop but I just to give you guys an idea
it's like this coming out of his ass
right yeah yeah a little more pleased at
least people are saying now Zach is
definitely Meredith after hearing this
yeah I feel that it for sure looks like
a sweet potato yeah exactly it's bigger
than that though yeah like a like a like
a large sweet potato like one of those
like misshaped yams you know if his
butthole's here
right so the whole big ass prolapse
comes out this much yeah it's even
bigger more wide it's less red and they
just have a lot of fun with it it's so
incredible Jesus Christ so I don't know
maybe we could get him to call in
because like I'd love to hear about that
isn't this this is all aren't we after
dark territory well c-man talked about
getting jerked off by three no but I'm
just saying isn't this guy an
established character in The Howard
verse are we like are we they know he's
never talked to him really they've only
ever so we could scoop Howard oh well no
I don't care I want to talk to him yeah
he's some of Howard's correspondents has
spoke no but he's never directly been
one-on-one conversation no who cares
Howard's the guy's gonna retire in like
two months okay fair enough I can reach
out the people demand I actually really
wanted to eat look no despite what you
think of it's gross or whatever
uh I think he's a fascinating guy
talented I agree let's get let's get
Hunger FF okay I'll reach out oh Lord
ow I might be sick that day oh people
using the sweet potato Emoji in the chat
this is horrible oh this is horrible
don't do that gross
I mean I'm so interested like first of
all how he discovered this passion how
did he grow it out you know
do people got a lot of questions
also they have like they have
um
they have like conventions where this
guy's the star of the show and everyone
gets to stick stuff up his ass fist
first fist Fest yeah love to hear about
that does he get paid for Fish Fest or
is that just like everyone's comes in
and partying I think it's well if he's a
headliner I would hope he gets paid I
don't know if that's what it is just
there I think it's the Love of the Game
Dude That's What I yeah
that's what I imagined but uh there it
is
a hunger
this Fest Zach reach out to that man
howling uh one of the great talents of
of our day there's a hunger for this
character to come back yeah so um
anything else since we're on the topic
of hunger FF fascinating stuff for this
hunger uh you know what we should show
it to Howie oh and when Howie comes on
we gotta show him
the king of prolapses and get his take
alive prolapsing I'll ask him Howie do
you think this is covid related or when
Howie comes in
we have hunger FF come and show us roll
I would [ __ ] die is he in L.A can you
find out yeah if we can get Hunger FF to
pull his prolapse out we can't show no
no we show reaction shots no we'll have
to show Howard reacting to it and he's a
judge so he can he can give it a rating
holy [ __ ] we have to do that oh I'm
gonna reach out to him yeah obviously we
won't show the pro Labs down we'll be
off screen
yeah
maybe for behind the scenes
I'm kidding
well do we well we could upload it on
Twitter
they don't give a [ __ ] over there
oh man we would totally upload that to
Twitter dude [ __ ] what we could do
behind the scenes is blur the prolapse
that might not that will get age
restricted but maybe not a strike right
but I don't know if I want to risk yes
holy [ __ ] imagine how he walks into this
not knowing that what's going to happen
well we got to keep it on the deal oh
this is this is the perfect way to it's
the perfect uh
Crescendo he assaulted our eyes I feel
like it's different in person well
that's we have to find out this guy's
like the goat of prolapsing he's a
really nice guy yeah I have no doubt
about that we just we have to show Howie
that if you're gonna do a prolapse
you've got to do it right you gotta do
it and this is correct 16 inches of ass
meat absolutely he grew it out I heard
you don't have to look if you don't want
to do them all right we'll definitely
not be you're not even gonna look at it
no I don't first I just do that
the one the science the Neil one makes
me gag every time I look at it and this
is like this guy is the greatest of all
time I don't like baseball I don't care
play baseball though I don't care like
people overuse the word though this man
is the actual ghost right this man is
the goatse man
there's gonna be a dude with 16 inches
of ask me and you're not gonna take I
will avert my eyes oh come on Dan what
do you mean come on well please
wait does that mean it touches the floor
or no no no no no probably close though
yeah that's what I'm saying is maybe by
the time it comes in floor level
no I've never seen it that much
he says the width of it according to him
is like the size of a grapefruit yeah
makes sense
this I'm very excited about please make
this I'm gonna get on it right when we
uh I'll do anything it takes to get the
Spanish show this has asked me and Howie
I need this okay
we got to get a reaction cam on Dan in
the top corner
during this whole thing
Dan just a reminder
years ago at this point you said if I go
under 200 pounds we're going to lube the
Dome up in mayonnaise does that still
stand of course it does nice yeah the
whole point was to act as a dome the
whole point was to motivate you and if
you're doing it now absolutely I will
make good on that problem get that Mayo
I'll hate it but we'll do it it's still
a long ways away but I can already do it
though we did something we didn't like
the Silent Library I thought yeah it was
frosting it was Mayo okay fair enough
but yeah no I will I will not back down
off of that hey I wonder if we should do
another silent library because
um I always see people talking about how
they love that episode so much
that was a good while ago now was it not
it was a year ago it was a year ago and
two days
it was really a year ago already how do
you know it was my 9 11. no I think I
remember
wow around Thanksgiving time because
wasn't there a no that was a similar one
I know what you're talking about that
was a similar one
I think we should do another one like
that though those are hits man oh yeah
that was fun September 30 2021. the
thing is though that was when that was
before we went all live and it would be
a little trickier to do it not live so
maybe I wasn't wrong I mean we could do
it live but
we could do it live we just have to
really really really do repair we might
need some extra hands too right yeah was
that the first time we did fika fish too
I think it was I think it might yeah
we'll do it live and the spicy the first
time Amy saw God through spicy food
right and first time Ian down that Pico
fish that was super uh Legendary
Legendary moment yeah baby and I also
had a intimate moment you guys piss or
something no I I ate his bra he ate the
candy bra I had on but I was like
messing around caressing his hair and
I'd expect him like to go down when he
did and it was just a beautiful I bit a
little piece of his nipple off
oh yeah he was slobbering through my
shirt oh guys this is a preview of ab's
card this is pretty good I like this
it's clever
it's a b boxing on the Donkey Kong
that's pretty cool yeah do you have
Sam's idea sir that's a good one really
clever that's a good one in the jungle
no less oh because it's Donkey Kong yeah
okay we love that Rumble and jungle baby
we love it
oh but you know people say oh Ethan's
the new [ __ ] David dobrik dude David
dilbrick never showed ask me
period
period on God
you also haven't met you Mickey shows
you haven't maimed anyone
so all you guys know eyes yeah
slight difference there you know not yet
yeah not yet anyways Bobby Lee almost
died but he's fine on the Gatsby that
was his own damn choice in fact we
almost begged him not to do that so
yeah still one of the greatest moments
selling on show history you know it's so
[ __ ] funny that that was true didn't
he say once that he did it on purpose he
did he did do it on purpose he's a
lunatic that's so funny
could have easily broken his leg
yeah that was I was literally begging
him not to do it I was like there's zero
need for you that's why to do this some
people in the audience probably haven't
seen it was a long time ago yeah oh a
lot of people are saying ghost husting
hunting we are planning another good
yeah we're working on something special
for her we're gonna have a really fun
special Halloween one for you guys so
um yeah
that's a fun tradition I mean the last
one was so fun so great
okay
here is the faded Bobby Lee crashing the
Gatsby
moment so funny please enter yeah right
now here we go
his leg was like pinned
between the this was the last time we
did this too he ruined it for everybody
we realized that this may
well look how far yeah
oh yeah and his leg was really pinned
between the Gatsby and the wall it
looked like he was very injured so I
mean like he starts all the way across
the room and I remember I kept I'm like
it's a piece of paper you don't need to
like get up speed and just have the
Gatsby right on the other side of the
paper so you can just
go right through and he's like no no I'm
doing it from back here no no I'm doing
it for me he's the showman man thanks
Dan
let me watch that again
here we go
and then that's the moment when Carlisle
knew that this relationship would not
work
yeah yeah we there was a time when we
put up a big print of the guest face and
they would drive the Gatsby through it
yep and this was the last time for
obvious reasons that happened so there
you have it there you have it
all right see you guys tomorrow with the
members only podcast thank you guys so
much thank you to everyone who's
watching we will be back on Wednesday
for a new slamming full week of the week
of the issue podcast love you guys
it's fall actually now officially right
it sure is so that's exciting shout out
to our 800 new members today
let's go thank you guys
great glad you all are excited welcome
yeah
yeah
[Music]
all right thank you guys see you next
time see you next Tuesday
see you next Tuesday
[Music]
[Music]